Alex Jones is back on X formerly known
as Twitter Elon Musk ran a poll the
people spoke they said we want Alex
Jones back and so Elon Musk has restored
him following this Elon Musk Alex Jones
the tape Brothers VI Gras Swami many
others joined a an xpace we call them
spaces and uh uh it was particularly
interesting talking about free speech
and where we're currently at Alex Jones
went on Steven Crowder's show talking
about the pr firms that were going after
him and interestingly all day Rumble has
been under a sustained distributed
denial of service attack which I can
only assume is political based on what's
going on the media of course is losing
their Collective minds and another
component of the story is that
apparently during the the space on X
theas Swami left his mic on and relieved
himself in the bathroom uh while
everyone listened and I I don't believe
that's true that's what they're claiming
it actually kind of sounds like I don't
know he was washing his hands or making
an espresso or something it certainly
does not sound like he's using the
bathroom but his mic was left on so
we'll talk about that we got a bunch of
other stories ladies and gentlemen it is
a a victory victory victory kind of day
starting off especially with the return
of not just Alex Jones but also Owen
Shroyer who's out of jail and we're also
hearing that not just the president of
upen but also one of their board members
I believe the chair have resigned over
this major Scandal and Saturday Night
Live is getting slammed because guess
what guess who they sided with they made
a least stonic the Republican rep looked
stupid they mocked her and tried to make
the presidents of these universities
look good the interesting thing is the
president of Harvard apparently is now
embroiled in a plagiarism Scandal so
we'll get into all that but before we
get started my friends head over to the
best song ever.com and click pre-order
on Amazon which uh you can see right
there and uh buy the song for 69
together again is the best song ever
written and I can say it cuz I didn't
write it it was written by uh I don't
know who the writing credits go to but
it is written and performed by Smoky
Mike and the god king who you probably
know as Jeremy boring and Michael nulls
of the daily wire and let me just give
you the simple version they wrote this
song essentially as a big Fu to the
music industry that says no Outsiders
and is captured by the woke and we wrote
Our cover of their song mocking modern
music for much the same reason and the
whole point of the song is basically
just a mockery of the music industry
being captured by woke institutions the
music video and song drops December 15th
so this Friday but you can pre-order
right now and if we sell enough of these
through iTunes or Amazon we will hit the
Billboard charts and then that middle
finger will be on their in in their own
industry and wouldn't that be something
so if you want to support us in ende
never ende never please do so also head
over to
timcast.net if you would like to watch
the members only uncensored show coming
up at 10 p.m. and if you want to support
our work directly this is the best way
to do it you'll also get access to our
Discord server where you can hang out
it's effectively a big chat room where
you can hang out with like-minded
individuals and they have pre-shows they
have after shows there's a whole bunch
of content being made there so don't
forget to also smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends if you really do like
it joining us to talk about this and
everything else is Anna Perez yeah thank
you for having me Tim and everyone I'm
really excited to be here and uh I uh
oops I have to bring my mic closer um
and I host a show on wrong called wrong
think on conservative daily I host a
show called wrong thinkink Prime Time on
the St Peters network uh so yeah I'm
really excited to jump in obviously we
have a lot of news as it pertains to
rumble so that affected me today so
excited to talk about bunch of people's
streams were shut down yeah and
interestingly right around the time
Steven Crowder was talking to Alex Jones
I couldn't get the site to load so yeah
we'll talk we'll talk about it thanks
for hanging out and guess who's back
welcome back beautiful and amazing human
beings my name is zurad here of we are
change.org and it's an incredible time
to be alive it almost feels like it's a
Renaissance we have an anarchistic
president of Argentina that is firing
bureaucrats about to shut down their
Central Bank Owen tryer was just
released from jail Alex Jones was just
reinstated and did a space with Elon
Musk Andrew Tate Patrick bad David
Congressman Matt Gates holy freaking cow
it definitely seems like the tide is
turning I host of course thepolitical
show.com and if you want to support me
you can by getting one of these
wonderful shirts that I have right now
perfect for family gatherings that talk
about how Christmas likes are like blank
according to blank blank blank which you
could find out what it says by going to
of course the best political shirts.com
guys thank you so much for having me
it's good to be back it is good to have
you back Luke I love you man it's a
pleasure uh yo it does feel like
something's changing big time like
there's something's coming to a head
that like PE that the people are
separating the ones that are willing to
risk and sacrifice their lives for what
they believe in or stand standing out
like it it's really really hit me hard
the other night so I let's just get to
this Serge what's happening Brother word
up good to have you back Luke
Ser uh yeah I'm surge.com I'm ready when
you are to all right ladies and
gentlemen the big news over the weekend
and uh we're using Snopes for our story
here because believe it or not the least
biased story about The Return of Alex
Jones sort of is Snopes fact check yes
Alex Jones's X account was reinstated by
Elon Musk the founder of conspiracy
theory website Infowars was banned from
Twitter currently known as X in 2018 and
reinstated in 2023 now I I do want to
just point out if you're going to call
Infowars a conspiracy theory website I
can call Snopes CNN The Washington Post
the New York Times The Wall Street
Journal the list goes on we can call
them all conspiracy theor uh conspiracy
theory websites because they all run
stories and have historically done so
like the idea that the government was
spying on us conspiracy theory oh was
that true how about Russia gate that was
one that wasn't true they all run lies
and conspiracies but they do use this
photo of a very angry looking Alex Jones
claim in December 2023 conspiracy
theorist Alex Jones's Twitter account
real Alex Jones was reinstated by Elon
Musk after having been banned for
abusive Behavior since 2018 true I love
this one and then on a they show a
Reddit post Alex Jones and his
conspiracy theories are allowed back on
X here's the actual Poland question with
one
9661 125 votes reinstate Alex Jones on
the platform vox populi Vox day and uh
70.1% said yes well there you have it of
course the media is absolutely losing
their mind over the return of Alex Jones
they're saying a whole bunch of really
dumb things and they're insulting Elon
Musk over the whole thing but uh let's
just call this a a major victory well
conspiracy theories are really just uh
spoiler alerts uh they're just news
headlines 6 months ahead of the time and
I am pissed off at the cultural
appropriation of something that I've
been labeled for over 20 years
conspiracy theories have of course a new
day and age on this internet as of
course no one takes the term seriously
anymore as a lot of the people who are
accused of it have usually been right
and it's beautiful it's amazing to see
this kind of emotional hyperbolic
freakout from CNN from the Rolling
Stones from all these other
establishment type Rags that are losing
their minds people just being able to
speak for themselves and having
discernment and having conversations
that they can't control Al Gore recently
came out and said the dangers to
democracy are specifically because
people are able to get news outside of
the corporate media control we are
winning it's amazing it's beautiful and
them losing their mind is a testament to
just how far we have come yeah and I
think that that's exactly what they
sought to do they really thought that
they could get rid of Alex Jones and I
think that's been really interesting to
watch because if there's one thing that
I've noticed in the past couple of years
it's that they can cancel you from
certain platforms they can cancel you
from certain corporate corporations but
at the end of the day if you have a
certain following and you've been proven
right time and time again and that's
certainly the case with Alex Jones
you're still there's still going to be a
population of people that want to hear
from you they're going to seek you out
and as far as a business owner somebody
like Elon Musk if he's you know if he
owns X then it's going to be the smart
thing to do to allow him to be sought
out on his platform so I I think what
you see a lot with figures like Alex is
they just they try to they think that if
they remove the platform that they can
remove him but he already has his
following and that wasn't going anywhere
people were going to seek him out
regardless
Andrew oh on the show on The X episode
if you haven't watched it after this
show you got to watch The X show where
with all these guys on and Andrew Tate
came in he said everything people think
they own things you think you own your
house you have paperwork that says it if
a government comes in and says now they
sign some new paperwork you don't have
anything all you have is your integrity
and that's something that Alex has stuck
with for his entire career which I
appreciate and I think that's why he's
still popular I think Elon Musk is doing
the the obvious thing in terms of free
speech I don't believe that Elon Musk
ever really bought the reason for Alex
Jones's ban so uh when Elon buys Twitter
he says well you know Alex Jones ragged
on you know Sandy Hook families and said
horrible things about him so I'm not
bringing him back I don't think Elon
actually believed it I think what Elon
was actually saying and again my my
opinion I could be totally wrong about
this cuz I can't read elon's mind he was
probably saying guys there's only so
much I can do like give give me time I
think Elon was like yeah he didn't break
the rules he's just says crazy things
but but elon's like yo we're trying to
maintain control here and gradually move
the line if we just go nuts and just
unleash the damn right now we can get
shut down like they did to parlor but I
think there's actually something really
simple in all this too we can sit here
and say Elon Musk is ideologically
motivated and fighting the good fight
sure but let's be realistic about the
business prospects of what he did on X
like you mentioned Alex Jones's audience
still exists so the analogy I gave
earlier on my channel was like the poll
Elon Musk did was like imagine you owned
a cupcake shop and all your customers
are in the lobby and you just yell how
many of you would buy a pumpkin cupcake
and they all rais their hand well then
you go and make it it's it's that that's
it Elon mus is asking his customers what
kind of product they want but here's the
funny thing just like with the daily
wire making all these movies Elon Musk
is looking at Alex Jones getting
millions of views while being banned
from everywhere and he's thinking if why
let Alex Jones on Twitter I have a
monopoly on Alex Jones all his content
is going to be here it's going to bring
all of his fans back it's going to bring
engagement to the platform we're going
to make money let's roll and it pushes
the Overton window and I think it's not
an accident that a lot of this is
happening on the heels of Apple Disney
Comcast and other major corporations
saying hey uh we're no longer going to
advertise on of course Twitter and X
Elon Musk responded saying uh in a very
French way uh screw off and by doing so
so this is he he could say it but but
when his actions are are met by bringing
back Alex Jones that's the biggest F off
kind of moment that you could have that
are far more powerful than just the
words that he used but but but imagine
because it's not just you know these
corporations it's not just Facebook it's
not just uh YouTube it's not it's not
individuals Banning Alex Jones from all
these social media platforms there are
federal agents that orchestrated all of
this there are federal a agencies that
literally worked on silencing and making
sure that no one could hear Alex Jones
his opinions or his perspectives at all
imagine being that federal agent right
now a couple years ago be like yes we we
banned him on Spotify we banned him on
on all these other LinkedIn he's not
even on LinkedIn doesn't matter we
banned him here we banned him here we
banned him here and now he's on one of
the biggest shows with Elon Musk
speaking to the world with millions of
people listening to him and more and
more people are going to go to that
platform I know I am one one of our
super chats Greg duva says that he's
he's asking the elites would still have
control of Twitter if they didn't uh ban
The Babylon B and I said I said I bet
they regret that every day I don't think
that's the real reason Elan musk bought
Twitter and I say this because I was at
a party in Austin with a bunch of big
Tech Bros and people who are friends
with with Elon and a bunch of other
conservative commentators and
Libertarians and the whole conversation
was around how they use big Tech to
censor and control culture and I was
arguing with them like guys culture is
more important than technology
technology is important but like winning
the culture matters and their argument
Elon wasn't there anything but their
argument was basically if they ban you
you can't make culture at all if on
Twitter they have banned all instances
of a certain word then they are forcing
you know they' have basically created
created a a path that only the only path
you can go down and so unsurprisingly
Elon Elon ends up buying the platform it
may be that the final straw was the
Babylon B got banned I think that's a
good narrative especially for someone
like Elon but I I kind of feel like this
is a long time coming I think elon's
paying attention to all this stuff he
didn't adopt these views one day you
know it's not like all a sudden he like
what they ban The Babylon be all of a
sudden I'm for free speech oh he he's
probably supported this stuff for a very
long time yeah and I think well it's a
similar concept to kind of the Sigh up
of every single conservative needs to
move out of cities here's the reality
somebody has to make a cultural
difference and right now the only way to
really do that is to have some sort of
uh influence on in cities on where the
cultural hubs are now is that good
culture that we have right now no but
it's the same thing as social media
platforms like as much as we don't want
to have to participate in you know
walking around uh walking on eggshells
when it comes to these social media
platforms like we did for so long with
Twitter we have to have a presence on
these apps on these social media
Platforms in order to make some sort of
cultural change as conservatives and so
I think you're right Elon did the right
thing Elon did something where he saw
okay well the only way for this for
there to be a fair sort of you know
cultural balance out there would be to
give conservatives the opportunity to be
on this app and uh I think it he it
wasn't necessarily like a political move
per se although he'll argue he's free
speech I don't think the guy is I don't
I I I think that if he were he would
bring back Nick Fuentes um and I think
that he wouldn't have created the poll
and maybe we differ on that or we
disagree on that but I think that the
poll was all about self-preservation and
was more about and and to to be fair
feds would have come after him too so to
your point like you know there were feds
involved in silencing people like Alex
Jones and even Nick ventes others like
that so uh I think it's all about well I
can point back to this was the people's
decision and they might still come after
him but at the end of the day like I do
think that was partly an opportunity for
himself to Pro for him to protect
himself but I think ultimately he did it
for there to be some sort of balance out
there which I I think is good but again
not necessarily politically motivated
that's that's a good point uh if he was
for free speech he wouldn't need a poll
he'd just say Alex you're fine Nick
you're fine Milo you're fine you're back
don't worry about it they wouldn't have
banned yay West yay is still banned
right I believe so and so so Milo as
well yay posted the realism symbol which
looks like a star of Da with a swastika
in it but realism like what what is it
like they believe aliens or something
seated Earth I don't I don't know what
they believe but it but it it to those
who have no idea what it is it looks
like something meant to be offensive he
gets banned for this I think if El was
for free speech he wouldn't need a poll
that's a good point and I think maybe
elon's motivation is actually simple he
wants to colonize Mars he wants neural
link and he's thinking look that that
Meme he posted where it's the left
moving further and further left he's
realized what many of us have realized
you said as conservatives I don't
consider myself conservative and Luke
doesn't consider himself conservative
this Coalition of individuals who
believe in free speech is is is wide
Elon probably said the majority of
people think these things I wouldn't be
surprised if he had like a marketing
consultant and he was like where is the
sentiment are they really you know Lefty
and woke and they're like no it's
probably like 12% elon's like okay so
our path forward for popular success is
going to be embracing these principles
that people actually do like yeah he he
probably sees the wind moving in a
particular direction especially with
this election and he's like okay how do
we get ahead of it how do we put our
sales in a way where we could still win
while the whole system kind of collapses
onto itself so I I I agree with you on
on that one particular Point yes he's
trying to kind of protect himself with
this poll but but I don't think it's
even the poll I think it's even bigger
than this if you look at his contracts
with the defense industry with the US
military with the Pentagon when it comes
to starlink when it comes to providing
Ukraine and Israel satellite technology
that are used for defensive and
offensive capabilities those
capabilities are at his disposal to use
and Implement as he wants that to me in
my opinion is why he's going to be kind
of protected here and if it wasn't for
those kind of larger government
contracts and the larger kind of game
that he plays with a lot of the bigger
kind of um players here I think he would
have been gone I think he would have
been destroyed a long time ago and I
think this really does play a central
role in a lot of this so I got Alex
Jones pulled over right here and one of
his tweets from 22 minutes ago Jack
bobic issues emergency warning deep
State planning direct war with Russia as
October surprise now excuse me this is
from uh Jack bobic Alex Jones putting
out this information this is exactly why
they don't want Alex Jones having a
voice cuz y'all remember when Alex Jones
went on a show and said that come
February there's going to be a war it's
going to be big and uh then when Russia
invaded Ukraine everybody immediately
was tweeting Alex Jones was right he
predicted this they were all sharing
this clip from several months prior my
favorite thing about this is everyone's
like how did Alex Jones know a war was
going to start how did he know he's just
so smart he can see it and so I I talked
to him and he was like I just read the
news it was in the news like it this is
the funny thing Alex is a guy who reads
the news and then says it he like looks
at all these articles and brings them
together granted he says a lot of crazy
things he gets crazy things wrong like
he talking about cell phones and animal
hybrids whatever that's about but he
gets a lot of things right when it comes
to this stuff it wasn't shocking to
anybody who actually listens to him that
he accurately called out a war because
all he was doing was holding up like
articles from the AP what he's doing
here with retweeting Jack bobic he's not
actually exactly that's my point and
it's not just him it's members of the
Polish government members of the German
government coming out one of German's uh
Germany's top solder just came out and
said that they are of course planning on
potentially even having a defensive war
against Russia of of course there's
there's no such thing it's an offensive
War but this is something that it's not
just Alex Jones talking about government
officials are actually talking about
this and setting down essentially the
groundwork for what could be a big
potential conflict that could
potentially uh unfold especially right
before this election I want to pull up
this tweet from Steven Crowder it is
from his discussion with Alex Jones this
morning he says quote this was a
strategic Democratic party in PR
operation Alex Jones clears the air on
why his Twitter account was banned how
it feels to be reinstated on X by Elon
as well as what his future plans are so
let me uh let's play this clip that so
so we can hear it right from Crow show
because of something to do with Sandy
Hook and um a lot of people think that
you were banned from Twitter because of
something to do with Sandy Hook and Elon
clarified that the reason you were
banned from Twitter had to do with that
sniveling worm Oliver Darcy nothing to
do with Sandy Hook but the actual reason
for sending him was he he basically
insulted a journalist they he PL form us
uh for a bunch of madeup crazy stuff the
last thing was Oliver Darcy later before
they ever sued me they were saying I'm
the Cy Hook guy and I'm attacking the
families and sending people to their
houses and none of it was true and no
one was even going to their houses and
people were peeing on Graves and none it
was true none of that was even shown in
court they were allowed to just get up
and say it with no evidence because I
was already found guilty right and so I
started saying hey I think it happened
I'd already said that by the way I I did
an apology Tour on Joe Rogan and Patrick
mavid before I even got sued and said
hey here I am years ago saying I think
it happened they said oh now you admit
you lied and did it for money this was
strategic Democratic party PR firm
operation um a lot of people think that
I uh I I think so I think we know for a
fact that right now as we're entering
2024 I mean so this was back in 2018
entering 2024 we have I'm not going to
name the groups and you guys can if you
want to they're these uh uh Democrat PR
Democrat uh uh uh nonprofit 51 C4 type
organizations all they do is launch
lawsuits in order to win elections if
you think the 2024 election is simply
how many people can go and cast their
ballot you're wrong a whole lot of it is
going to be procedural fights it's going
to be Court battles and I think a big
component of why not just Alex Jones
because it it it was a coordinated move
that got him banned like we we can see
him wiped from every platform instantly
but there were many other people Paul
Joseph Watson got banned from Instagram
and what did he have he had pictures of
him like smoking a cigarette by the Sun
set just like ridiculous things like
what are you Banning him for it is
political moving into 2024 I would not
be surprised if we see a ton of moves
like this that being said with Elon Musk
owning X it's going the other direction
we're starting to win this one
especially with other institutions like
Rumble out there now uh Rumble also has
a very interesting lawsuit against uh
some of these you call them Democratic
organizations I call them more
government Intel connected organizations
that are also financed with billionaires
individuals names
uh like George Soros who of course do
play a major role in our political
discourse so uh when you see the kind of
coordinated attacks that happened a
couple years ago it it wasn't social
media it was government officials we
found that out through the Twitter files
we found that out through all the
disclosures we found out that US
government officials FBI officials Intel
officials were saying hey we don't like
what these people are saying shut down
these individual voices they're talking
about this kind of news reporting that
we don't like shut them down immediately
and they did your tax dollars
essentially financed a lot of this and I
really hope that these new lawsuits uh
really shed a light and we have a lot of
Discovery specifically when it comes to
the larger involvement of outside forces
not just Democratic organizations that
are playing a major role here well you
mentioned Soros and I think that's
actually really crucial part to all of
this because for so long the way that
they got you to not ask questions or
file lawsuits was uh they kind of
associated s insulting Soros criticizing
Soros with you being anti-semitic or you
know calling you names throwing labels
at you and that was actually quite
effective for a few years there I would
say between uh Trump running in 2015 to
about 2019 that was pretty effective to
throw certain labels at you then I think
uh Americans started to wake up by and
large people who weren't even political
by Nature they started to realize okay
these labels don't actually mean
anything because my next door neighbors
being called a racist for having a
Gadson flag or something like that they
started to realize these labels didn't
mean anything then they started actually
investigating it uh who Soros really is
I think more Americans are aware of
these strategies that the left have has
used for so long or just the you know
the uni party at large to silence us
this idea that you can't question
anything Americans are aware more than
ever before that we've been lied to
about not just the government but about
who these people are that we're
surrounded by in our communities and you
know we look around like you know the
people who who were silen very early on
um and and we're like like Milo
yannopoulos for example or Gavin
McKinnis and it's like these people are
not who they told us they were yeah you
know I I know the exact moment when the
when the tides turned it was when Taylor
Swift called out George Soros several
years ago I'm half kidding by the way
but Taylor Swift calls out the Soros
family because they undercut her and I
do think that that does open the door a
little bit for people to criticize this
George Soros a lot of conservatives are
attacking Taylor but I'm like dude she
put out this big post talking about how
her music was stolen from it's not
political at all but now well now
there're going to be a lot of people who
are critical of George Soros in a
completely apolitical context you can't
call them all anti-semitic anymore right
and I think that's what it took to bring
it into the mainstream because Taylor
Swift is in the mainstream I think
that's a really really good point I
actually think it's like it's true like
I mean like I think that in order to
make something to be effective you need
to somehow bring it into the mainstream
it can't just be a like political junky
talking point this is why I think it's a
scop all these conservatives attacking
Taylor Swift cuz all of a sudden these
accounts on Twitter are like Taylor's
working for Soros and I was like what
she doesn't like the guy she's posted
against him take the opportunity man
take the win you got I think this would
be a really great video for Freedom
Tunes where it's like a bunch of
17-year-old girls screaming George Soros
ripped off Taylor Swift and then he is
calling them all anti-semites it's a
shame that that guy's not here but but
uh anyway I I I wanted to bring up
another Point here what what we were
just talking about because it was Alex
it was Milo it was Gavin it was Robinson
a lot of big prominent individuals were
censored but more important certainly a
lot of kind of smaller upand cominging
content creators were also censored and
then obliterated and had their entire
careers destroyed they weren't the big
guys they weren't the big players that
could sustain these attacks and I I I
think truly the biggest damage that
happened was on all the people that were
coming up that we're going to have an
impact now that we're going to be
prominent that we're going to be big but
had no chance because the algorithm
screwed them over destroyed them
demonetized them and hurt our kind of
discourse more than we could even
imagine parlor would be Twitter right
now exactly that's crazy it's like War
gaming I mean if we're really concerned
with a war with Russia we have to look
at this as common sense realistic as
possible that these centralized services
are vulnerabilities like if if Elon
holds Twitter on a central service
Verizon can shut them down the
government can go in there and get his
whoever wherever they're hosted can shut
them down they need to decentralize this
service as quick as possible they need
like something like Brier or Noster or
something where we can run it on our
phones centralized because it's it's
just inevitable man because especially
with these infrastructure attacks
especially with what happened to to
rumble especially what R today and and
what will be happening probably to
Twitter as of course Twitter also had a
lot of very uh important infrastructure
problems and I think the next step if
they can't silence the person if they
can't silence the voice they're going to
silence the megaphone that people speak
through and and these are the attacks
that we should be keeping an eye out
right now well so so I wonder Elon Musk
gives the big Fu at that New York Times
event these advertisers are are are
cancelling and he says they're going to
be the ones that destroyed this company
I think we we we did briefly mention
this a couple weeks ago Elon Musk could
theoretically just say I am federating X
meaning it will be a decentralized open-
source infrastructure that connects to
all the other other
infrastructure and it will X will never
go anywhere then because now you're
integrated in this decentralized open
source Network he can easily offset tons
of the cost through open sourcing and
distributed uh uh uh uh
uh decentralizing servers and services
through the What's called the fediverse
and then there would be a major business
loss the big challenge with this is that
he took out loans to buy X but if x is
on the verge of collapse this may play
out poorly for him but I do think the
richest man whose net worth is currently
as of today estimated $244 billion I
kind of think he can stand to lose $44
billion and it's not just that hold on
like the there's investors involved they
would lose money but let's look let's
what's the worst case scenario Elon says
all the advertisers pulled off in a
coordinated fashion for seeming
political reasons you can't hold me
responsible for that X is now done what
do we do open source decentralizes our
best path to maintain the platform and
retain memberships and and advertising
the me the uh the Fede is great although
if they stay centralized on like big
data centers or in in AWS or Cloud
wherever they're hosting that can still
get shut out of the the fediverse so
you're looking versus a mesh Network
mesh networks which are like really up
and coming and they're challenging still
to transmit video cuz they're you know
cell phone to cell phone but you have 50
cellphones 48 of them go down the other
two are still connected with Twitter and
then that's how it'll work but if the
establishment is is really desperate
right and and they're about to lose a
lot of power and they're about to be
held accountable for all the horrible
things they did to us how far do you
think they're going to go to stop that
from happening I think we have to
examine that in a very critical way
because I think they're they're willing
to go very far I think they're willing
to do a lot of crazy things that we
can't even imagine right now to just how
far they will go to say hey um there's
going there's going to be no
accountability here there's going to be
no truth here because as soon as the
people find out the truth it's game over
for them it it's it they're so they're
so cornered they're they're so in a
fragile situation that that truly this
is a very dangerous time for for all of
us yeah I think wherever we're thinking
they're thinking a step ahead like I
think that they're aware that that would
be our plan b or plan C like I I think
they're fully aware of of the direction
this is headed in they wouldn't do the
things that they're doing or they
wouldn't have done the things that they
have done to us for years if they didn't
if they weren't able to think one step
ahead I mean it's the same argument you
can make for Donald Trump everybody's
like well you know we're so back he's
going to win whatever but I
mean it's we're talking about the Deep
State here there's just no there's
nothing that's too far for theme
completely I like the Titanic can crash
into an iceberg you know you you can you
can there's a lot of conspiracies about
that too sure an analogy I'm not making
it literal it you can build the biggest
ship you can design it to to rip through
ice and then you come across bedrock and
be like we did not expect that to happen
we calculated and then boom We tore the
hole and now we're sinking it's possible
sure they can see far ahead and they may
be thinking Abandoned Ship yeah there's
a lot of Bankers there against the US
Federal Reserve but that's a different
story but yeah I I I do believe uh that
you you could be correct in your
sentiments but but just understanding
how they work and what they did to the
people especially within the last 3
years uh especially with within the last
22 years especially what happened in New
York City when when you calculate all of
their moves and decisions nothing is is
out of the realm of possibility here to
how far they will go uh to stop people
from finding out what they're really up
to well let me pull up this tweet here
from Chris pavlovski the CEO of Rumble
he tweets I can confirm this attack has
been unprecedented and has been
happening since this weekend Rumble for
those that are just uh uh for just
tuning in has been under a Cyber attack
and this may be related to Alex Jones uh
but look let's be real I Rumble is
really challenging the machine Alex
Jones was restored on X and it was
announced that he would be appearing on
Steven Crowder's show this morning all
of a sudden Rumble is slammed Viva fry
tweeted I was planning to go live but
Rumble and locals are down apparently is
a it is a massive unprecedented attack
one that is likely politically motivated
if I have any updates I'll let everyone
know godp speed Rumble
Chris pavlovski followed up by saying I
also suspect it is political coming from
activists and our organizations who want
to censor our creators and related to j6
videos being posted on Rumble 2024 is
two weeks away it is going to be wild
when he was in I was like you got to
decentralize this service and I I I know
he knew I was right and we also both
know the the momentous amount of effort
that would require and especially the
the challenge to to stream video from
like a mesh but I know Chris is thinking
about it he's a server Master but as
long as that Rumble thing is on local
servers or centralized on Big Data man
you are it is Target Target Target and
it's like when you're a Sitting Duck man
you're in you're in a rough position as
a tech company now who's really behind
these attacks that's a question that I'm
kind of asking myself I have my clear
speculations I have a clear answer to
who would be invested in stopping these
conversations from happening but Rumble
is on the on the up and up it's becoming
a very serious contender to one of the
biggest online media companies in the
world a monopoly on the industry that of
course abuses their power routinely and
hosts particular shows and platforms
like um that are major And when they see
a competitor coming out and and and and
doing their job better and allowing the
free market to actually speak and
represent itself holy cow that is a
danger to their business that is a
danger to their industry and um I I
wouldn't be surprised if it's the
competition saying we got to shut it
down before they take our cake it could
be uh the Russians wanting you to think
that by making you think that the enemy
of your enemy is doing something to your
like it could be it could be three deep
you know it could be someone trying to
get you to think that it's Google doing
it to rumble or getting you to think
that it's the American government doing
it to rumble to so dissent but I think
the most obvious answer is it's someone
that didn't like the politics yeah
whoever is well I think I think you
bring up a good point I think often
times we have an enemy like the CCP for
examp example and a lot of times we see
these cyber attacks and it gets blamed
on the CCP and and it's peculiar because
even the people that do business with
the CCP will say that you know people
like Joe Biden and and the
administration and say oh it's the CCP
it's the CCP well I wonder how many
times they blame it on these other on
our enemies when really it's them uh
like you saw with the whole balloon
situation oh well it's the CCP but for
some reason we can't shoot it down um
well well we had our reservations about
that we weren't exactly certain that
that was the case uh given what the
government has done in the past but uh I
think that they do take advantage of our
enemies and they blame it on that I
think in the case of Rumble obviously
Rumble wouldn't be the ones to blame it
on a a fake enemy but I can see like
some sort of uh Story coming out blaming
it on the CCP or something like that or
maybe even Russia but uh I mean I I I
just I think as people who are in tune
with politics we have to be careful that
we don't allow them to use our enemies
as a way to as a way to get away from
their own responsibility of the fact
that they did it cuz the government's
obviously never going to tell us oh we
did it or or YouTube's never going to be
like we did it you know I don't think
we're ever going to find out who who's
really responsible here and who actually
did do it it could be a lot of different
people too working in conjunction
absolutely I think about a lot about the
CCP like that cuz I although I am
concerned with that authoritarian
economic you know autocracy whatever you
know oligarchy I guess communist it I
don't want to like say that's just the
purest evil on Earth and every cuz then
it's just going to send the US to war
with them and I don't want do that I
want to avoid that well the same thing
they did with Russia I mean they make
Putin out to look a certain way and it's
like they make him look like he's some
evil dictator but it's like no one
actually breaks down his reasoning for
what he's doing nobody actually and it's
a disservice to ourselves because then
we don't actually understand who we're
dealing with uh whoever side you're on
it's disservice to to not understand who
your supposed supposed enemy is uh but
they don't want you to think about that
because if you did think about it and
you did start researching it you might
actually realize that they've lied to
you about who he is and who our enemies
are in general so it's they they make it
out to be like oh don't question it
they're just your enemy it's just your
enemy don't question it but there are so
many people who just don't want to be
involved in politics and want to plug
their ears and just say la la la la la
they want to live in denial and uh you
know man I think they're the last ones
off the Titanic if they even make it off
the the people who are Imagine This
you're on the Titanic and uh hit an
iceberg and you were standing near the
front of the ship and saw it happen well
you knew what to do you knew okay bad
thing just happened for the people who
are like down in the ballroom just
having a good old time saying we don't
care we're not paying attention those
people didn't make
it there's going to be a lot of people
who don't make it right but but but at
the same time I I you know I say that
but I I think more than ever people are
are getting the opportunity to finally
speak to each other and find out what's
really going on I think there is an
opportunity to to awaken a lot of people
there are some people that still love to
have their heads in the sand and their
tickes up bare laid for whoever wants to
go out there and and take it uh and
those individuals I I think more and
more now especially with bomic
especially with the build back better
policies are seeing the real cost of
being ignorant to Politics As of course
if you ignore politics politics is not
going to ignore you and a lot of people
have been B Bamboozled have been screwed
over and now they're saying hey hold on
maybe I should be paying attention to
what's going on here because this
actually does have a real effect on my
life so in one sense yes I I do see
people kind of being blind to certain
situations but but I do see those blinds
being lifted now more than ever I assume
it's people with young children or
people that want to have young children
they have a reason to think outside the
box about the future but like older
people that are just collecting their
social security they're just like go
shut up and I want to just watch TV but
but but there's a a new data that was
just released by a CNN poll Donald Trump
I think it's in Michigan has a lead of
40 points among people who did not vote
in 2020 Trump's biggest gains are among
non-voters like people who didn't vote
are waking up and they're deciding I'm
voting for Trump and that's what's
giving Trump the bump good news yeah and
every time the corporate media attacks
him viciously uh unfairly he just
becomes more popular every time the
state brings more charges to him
everyone's like hey why are you doing
this to this man as of course he's
facing 750 years in jail which is
absolutely crazy the fact that a former
president of the United States could be
going to jail for multiple life
sentences that's just a new level of
craziness and and in my opinion
desperation by The Establishment that
has gone way too far but I I've talked
to a lot of people man Trump's Trump's
going to be convicted yeah now he now
the interesting thing is I could be
totally wrong why um Trump has
petitioned the Supreme Court and I
believe the Supreme Court has just said
they will take up the case Trump said
you cannot criminally charge a person
for what they did as president and I
believe he is correct you the president
must be impeached first impeached then
criminally charged uh the reason before
This Is War conflict crisis the people
need to say that this duly elected rep
representative is not fit because of
high crimes and misdemeanors afterwards
we can say what they do was criminal the
reason being if you could just
criminally charge a president whenever
you wanted then every state would file
criminal charges immediately against the
president because they didn't want him
to be president it it would be it would
be like imagine the Civil War once they
after the Civil War there's uh uh
they're having elections yeah a for a
former Confederate State would just be
like uh we're criminally charging the
president with these things yeah country
would never move forward what's going to
be the reaction of of the people when he
does get indicted when he does get
arrested he was indicted he was arrested
when he does get convicted convicted and
and put in jail but there's probably
going to be even more indictments
there's probably going to be even more
charges with the way that things are
going uh but but when he's in jail how
how will the American people respond
that's the question I think they're
listening to people like us and they're
wondering waiting for us to tell them
what to do that's like the scary part
kind of in a way is is like the not the
responsibility but also like how things
are hanging by a thread right now and
people need guidance I know what they
need to do they need to buy cbw coffee
the greatest cup of coffee I'm K also
work out
take point cuz Tucker was talking about
that the other day sort of he was saying
like you know I've because of all of
these indictments and everything like I
I've become a bigger Trump supporter is
what he's saying I think a lot of
Americans feel that way and I think that
would be a breaking point for a lot of
people and I don't you know it's hard to
say what they would do per se but I
think that that would certainly be
crossing the line for a lot of people
who in the past either voted for him
because they liked his economic policies
or thought he was a better option but I
think that as he gets indicted more and
more and that that's not even my opinion
this is these are just statistics too uh
more people are supporting him openly
and uh more fervently than ever before
and I think that means something for if
that does happen what if they do throw
him in jail uh I mean that'll ultimately
probably will mean he he would die the
guy's really old and and we all know
that they would Poss possibly do
something to him in prison right so how
how old is he 78 yeah in his late 70s
but it it it doesn't even matter like
they would you know they probably kill
him like they would find some way to
kill him and that's ultimately like I
think they probably blame it on age but
you know I mean who really knows it
could be that or well Al Alex Jones Alex
Jones warned about this yeah the the
risk to Trump's life because of of of
what's happening however I do think it's
also important to consider if we win
enough culturally and shift The
Narrative enough in this country it
would make the option of going after
Trump inviable right going after Trump
with with violence only matters if they
have the power to maintain control of a
system if it becomes apparent that you
know budl light's failure Disney's
failure uh this the the the expansion of
x if this becomes so apparent that we
are going to win what happens is the
powers that be just say oh I I was is
always for free speech and they'll jump
ship and quickly rush over because they
want to preserve their own lives so I
think all we have to do stay the course
build culture support uh uh daily wire
in their movie efforts uh uh support uh
shows like timcast Steven Crowder
support Jimmy door just
anti-establishment individuals buy the
best song ever go to go to the best song
ever.com buy our song pre-order it it'll
be out Friday the reason is we want to
win the culture War support uh mug Club
buy coffee brand coffee from Jeremy at
the quarter ring just support all of the
parallel economy go to Public Square buy
all your products from Public Square
just hammer down all these cultural
victories and make make sure they know
the money's not there the confidence is
not there and if you take Extreme Action
you will lose there's also we are
change. shop that's also pretty good but
uh no no t-shirts best political
shirts.com
but what I wanted to say to to kind of
add to your point they are playing a
very dangerous game game it is extremely
risky and some people have even
theorized that they're trying to push
the American people over the edge that
they're trying to kind of spur a
reaction to them that will create a
problem that they're going to have a
solution for so that's also something to
kind of think about here looking at
everything else but but as you mentioned
Tim a lot of people are are really
banking and hoping that the election is
going to solve a lot of problems for the
individual it's not what will solve the
problems are people taking personal
responsibility for themselves are people
who are going to decide to vote with
their clicks their likes their views
their dollars saying hey I'm going to
support the local Farm over there I'm
not going to support Walmart I'm not
going to support big factory farming I'm
going to go get some uh you know things
like raw milk if they're good for you
I'm going to actually do some homework
and Research into the ways that we are
being poisoned into the larger
biological war that is being waged on
men and women in this country I'm going
to make sure I am the strongest best
version of myself and I don't need the
system I'm not going to feed the system
I'm going to live outside of it in my
own free honest real way that right
there is a beautiful Act of resistance I
got I got a fact check Patriot with a
good fact check saying after being
convicted on impeachment charges Tim
president Trump was impeached he was not
convicted so I'll clarify what I'm
saying the argument from Trump is that
you must be impeached and convicted then
you can be criminally indicted and
criminally convicted Trump was impeached
which is effectively an indictment the
Senate voted no and then he was not
convicted so until that happens and he
is successfully convicted at following
impeachment none of this matters but
let's jump to this story from SC cnr.com
scanner Missouri AG launches
investigation into Media Matters AG
Andrew Bailey quote I'm fighting to
ensure Progressive tyrants masquerading
as news outlets cannot manipulate the
marketplace in order to wipe out free
speech this is huge Attorney General
Andrew Bailey says we have reason to
believe Media Matters used fraud to
solic IIT donations from missourians in
order to bully advertisers into pulling
out of X the last platform dedicated to
free speech in America we have launched
an investigation and it is quite simple
according to data from X as well as
numerous reports Media Matters appeared
to have created fake accounts or created
Created dummy accounts using new
accounts following specifically
advertisers and extremists that way the
content would appear next to each other
and they could then go to the advertiser
and say see look your content appears
next to extremists which is which is a
disingenuous version of events that
being the case for Media Matters to
claim this thing happened when according
to x their staff and Elon Musk it
happened like two times the argument is
Media Matters is defrauding donors by
tricking them into thinking they are
actually solving a problem when in fact
that problem doesn't even exist
therefore the argument now is fraud this
is huge but this is the law fair and
it's not just Missouri I know that I
believe uh Texas is is filing several
suits too right State the attorney
general attorney general there is doing
that yes let me let me let me read the
letter here so we can get the uh uh the
the specifics Here Andrew Bailey of
Missouri says this letter serves as a
formal document hold notice under
Federal and Missouri law the Missouri
attorney general's office has opened an
investigation into Media Matters for
America regarding your firm's
potentially unlawful business practices
full stop Media Matters is a I believe
they're are 501c4 nonprofit I could be
wrong but they all they do all day is
watch what they view as conservative
media and then post things often times
they're out of context or manipulative
but here's more he says as you no doubt
no doubt aware a federal laws has been
filed against Media Matters raising
serious allegations that your firm
falsely and deceptively manipulated the
algorithm on X formerly known as Twitter
through coordinated inauthentic behavior
and that you did so in an attempt to
defame the organization and C cause
advertisers to pull their support from
the platform thus harming free speech
the lawsuit alleges that you lie to the
public falsely suggesting that Fringe
extremist content regularly appears next
to content from corporate advertisers
when in fact the opposite is true at the
same time you appear to have used this
coordinated inauthentic activity to
solicit charitable donations from
consumers across the country I have
reason to believe that your firms
alleged actions may have violated
Missouri consumer protection laws
including laws that prohibit nonprofit
entities from soliciting funds under
false pretenses I'm especially concerned
that Media Matters actions have proven
true have hampered free speech by
targeting an expressly pro- Free Speech
social media platform in an attempt to
cause it Financial harm while defrauding
missourians in the process you are thus
hereby instructed to preserve all
records that may relate to your alleged
effort to engage in coordinated
inauthentic behavior on social media
Platforms in or in order to generate
false statements that were used to
solicit charitable contributions under
false pretenses you are instructed in
particular to preserve all records that
may relate to your web page which
expressly solicit funds at the following
URL he then goes on to list several
other documentation that must be
preserved so this is a notice to
preserve documents which means the
investigation is about to begin Missouri
expects to get into the discovery phase
and it mer very well may be that as we
enter 2024 the law fair ramps up
substantially more than just private
actors filing lawsuits and on top of
Missouri we may see I I got to be honest
I wouldn't be surprised if every single
state AG has some kind of lawsuit fired
away in an attempt to Advantage
themselves in this election it's not
just about votes it's not just about
vote policy it's about speech
capabilities yeah it's it's about Media
Matters trying to take down X and now
Missouri fighting to defend X because X
is in favor of free speech know 2024 is
going to be absolutely wild it already
is wild I know I'm just saying it's
going to get crazier it's going to get
way it's not just Media Matters it's so
many other organizations like that that
exist and I mean they could be you could
make an argument that they're doing the
exact same thing so this is really I
think this is huge this is really big to
to set this sort of precedent for you
know we will come after you if you try
to influence uh you know defraud people
essentially I mean that's the argument
they're making here and you know you
look at these other outlets like you
know right-wing watch uh what's the
other one the big one Patriot takes and
other ones like that where they take
things out of context and they could be
doing the same thing I don't know I mean
it it's worth they solicit donations
yeah so Rumble is suing uh check my ads
I believe the two founders and what this
group does is they contact advertisers
for various conservative outlets and
then try to get the advertisers to pull
out I can say they have made numerous
deceptive statements about us and used
that to solicit donations notably they
claimed that I pushed the quote unquote
big lie which is a CL uh the big lie
refers to Donald Trump saying he won in
2020 anybody who's ever watched this
show knows that I never claimed Trump
won 2020 and I actually argued with Bon
twice that Trump lost because people did
not like him and they want and they
didn't vote for Biden they voted against
Trump and Steve bennon actually went huh
that's that's I said Trump got anti-
elected there's no enthusiasm for Biden
they were voting against Trump and he
goes that's pretty good anti- elected
yeah so I'm like the fact that they
would raise money off of making that
claim it shows these organizations are
deceiving people in order to raise money
for the record they're a
501c3 Media Matters is med C3 no no no
no no yes I know they're not to wik
Wikipedia 501 from federal income tax so
how does that change this at all does it
make it more or less uh 501c3's can't
engage engage in partisan political
activity yeah and it's pretty clear that
they are
very super Pacs typically I believe
they're 501 C4s that's the tax
designation 501 then the C is in the
parentheses in a four and uh uh this 51
C4s don't have to disclose where their
money goes but it's not tax deductible
and uh 501c3 is completely tax
deductible but you can look up all their
information their salaries uh I
recommend everybody do this search for
tax form 990 and insert nonprofit and
you can learn a lot about all these
organizations so good SLO uh good sleo
thing uh everyone out there have
fun uh am I supposed to say something
now just Med you made the noise start
look for 90 media matter I was like I'm
one of those guys I want to know I want
to know who who owns it who runs it who
makes
salaries that's good and and and there's
a lot there's restrictions on this stuff
so should be interesting but uh I'm
curious to see where all these lawsuits
end up but uh uh regardless you know
it's not even 2024 yet okay primaries
haven't happened we're a month away from
the Iowa caucuses and already people are
starting to get crazy it feels crazy did
you guys hear CLA Schwab and I think
this video is real he said that he was
railing against anti-stem and saying
that there was Liber the biggest threat
to the system is Libertarians the
libertarianism it's it's it's like on
Twitter it was freaking me out like is
it's like this is the mask off moment if
this is a real video and he's speaking
out against libertarianism people who
believe in Freedom are the biggest
threat wa he had he had a mask on to
freedom to Freedom that's literally what
they say I love when they tell us to our
faces what they're trying to do like it
just it it just it drives home the point
that like they're not even they know
they don't have to be silent about it or
they think they have more power than
they do well it's because the average
person doesn't care that's true I can't
I can't tell you how many people I've
met who go oh well I don't I don't want
to I don't pay attention to that stuff
there's a viral video where this woman
is like I just went to Chipotle and my
burrito bowl was 1982 I know I got guac
but that shouldn't make it 1982 like WF
is going on and it's like well as you
sit there not paying attention uh your
burrito blls are becoming very expensive
now for those of us that are paying
attention we're like perhaps it was the
several hundred billion dollars spent in
foreign war garbage over the past couple
years and the massive spending that uh
resulted in hyperinflation well I
shouldn't say hyperinflation it's being
a little hyperbolic but you get my point
it's either you know giving everyone
$2,000 checks and big corporate bailouts
that's that's also another big issue
another big problem that of course I
think a lot of people need to uh deal
with as well but we are not in a in a
good situation there is a lot of law
fair now some people say there's too
much law fair I I would kind of agree
with them but right now it is very
heavily one-sided it is essentially
District Attorneys financed by George
Soros it is entally a lot of the leftist
organizations and groups that are kind
of organizing themselves and suing and
attacking everyone Alex Jones was sued
for a billion dollar Elon Musk is being
sued by those same individuals right now
so we we are sadly living in a day and
age where lawyers are becoming more
important but also uh more powerful and
more Rich than they ever were before
since this is how we are seeing this
kind of asymmetrical Warfare being waged
politically in in a very dangerous
Gambit that uh is not not good for
America it's not good for its people and
sadly now everything you do and say has
to be carefully monitored you have to
watch yourself you make one mistake
you're going to get sued into into
Oblivion and uh this is why the appeals
case for what's happening to Alex Jones
is so important as of course they they
they they found him guilty and he owes a
billion plus dollars for speech which he
he was found liable but this is the
important distinction here is that there
was no trial
people don't know this y people are
being told Alex Jones Lost a lawsuit and
is forced to pay over defamation no he
didn't it was it was a ruling in default
the judge said no trial for Alex Jones
you owe them you owe them now we're
going to have a hearing to determine how
much you owe them and he couldn't defend
themselves and the major accusation was
that he didn't uh provide Discovery uh
but ACC according to Alex Jones he was
providing Discovery he was providing a
lot of the documentations that they were
asking for he said that no matter matter
what he gave them they kept saying it
wasn't it and that's like how how do you
like it's like torture almost you know
the torturer says tell me the location
of the Genesis device and the guy goes I
don't know so they hit him again tell me
or else I seriously don't know he's
lying and they keep hitting you it's
like if you don't know what are you
supposed to say just lie so they're like
we want these documents and Alex's like
well there you go okay we want more he's
like that's it nope there's more you're
lying and he's like that's all I have
and they're like no default you lose
well that's the danger of this litigious
society and it's kind of what we've we
saw what Roger Stone too they did the
same thing to him they accuse him of
lying oh you didn't turn over all the
emails or you did this and therefore you
tried to lie about this and he was like
no that's not what happened uh but they
can keep pushing you and they can keep
pushing you and they can keep it in the
court system and they can keep making it
not only uh you know a a matter of like
the court but also the court of public
opinion too like they can keep you under
their thumb that way and they'll just
keep telling you you're lying you're
lying you're lying and then they make
you into a monster publicly and in the
court as to who you really are and
that's kind of what happened with Alex
Jones it happens with a lot of people
but I I think you're totally right this
litigious Society we live in is so
dangerous because it's like a what point
do do we stop because if they're if the
enem is going to be doing that right if
they're going to be throwing lawsuits at
everybody left and right then our only
way to defend ourselves is to throw
lawsuits at them in response which is
what you're seeing for example in
Missouri I bet artificial intelligence
will take that task on they'll start
using artificial intelligence to counter
Sue and Sue and counter Sue and it'll
just you see up
oh yeah there's going to be AI writing
like court documents it's going to be so
weird Let's uh let's jump to this story
cuz this one's this one's a good laugh
Business Insider writes Elon musk's luck
has finally run out is this it it's the
end for Elon oh no a good run Lynette
Lopez writing that uh Elon was on a
heater from 2019 to 2022 it seemed if
every single gamble he took was paying
off then he did what every risk addicted
blackjack player inevitably does pushed
his luck too far overconfidence
confirmation buys and delusions of
control LED to a string of bad decisions
and boom elon's Empire is in trouble
again oh no oh what's this the richest
man in the world Elon Musk
$244.00 want you to hear the truth Elon
Musk engaged in political Behavior
defending Free Speech buying a big Tech
platform and is winning he's got more Fu
money than anyone on the planet Tesla is
is slaying it cyber truck is coming out
everyone's super excited SpaceX has the
majority of all space launches and
they're like yeah well Elon musk's
failing because we don't like Twitter
anymore yo Mark Zuckerberg barely even
posts on threads anymore nobody uses it
but this is the narrative you know what
I think is happening is they're trying
to scare other people out of doing what
Elon Musk has done particularly
wealthier people but I think Americans
in general it's sort of they're using
him as a an example of of you know this
is what happens when you speak out when
you do something to go against when
you're a denter uh when you go against
what the state says is acceptable they
they want you to think that he's a
massive failure they want you to think
that if you were to even go you know
even try to do what he's done or go even
remotely close to that uh that the same
thing's goingon to happen to you that
everybody who does something that gets
involved in politics and takes an
opposing position to the state uh will
fail and you will fail too I think
that's what this is part of because they
try every time somebody does Ventures
out and tries to do something and
they're successful at it when it comes
to creating either you know a parallel
economy being a part of that or doing
what Elon Musk is doing which is
actually quite unprecedented honestly so
it's hard to compare it to anything else
but I think more than anything they just
want you to believe that you will fail
if you speak out if you do something
against the state that's why these
articles are coming out yep they'll take
your money they'll defame you they'll
destroy you they'll take everything that
they love from you but will they be able
to stop you absolutely not look what
happened to ow Shroyer look what
happened to Alex Jones look look what is
happening to all these individuals that
they did everything to stop and then
they have risen once again back up again
and and and and and this is a a big sign
this is a a huge case right now that
they desperately want to be true they
need it to be true because if it's not
it's showing people that free speech is
popular it's more popular than what the
corporate advertisers want it to be uh
it's more popular than the FED federal
government and the feds want it to be
and I I I think free speech is the big
winner here and even though they're
they're they're saying all this stuff it
doesn't mean it's true look at this
image they made of Elon Musk his
forehead getting red and his money
disappearing the dudes worth $244
billion he could lose all of Twitter and
it's $44 billion value not to mention he
didn't pay for the whole thing because
he got loans and he'd still be worth if
let's let's say he ate the whole cost of
Twitter and collapsed he's worth $200
billion that's I just I I I I I don't I
don't get it they're just trying to push
a narrative like you were saying Anna
they want you to think that you cannot
succeed doing this stuff who is they
this is I'm not understanding deep he
works Democrat okay got you're asking
who is they though it is Democrat and
neocon party establishment shills who
are mad that they can no longer control
the narrative it is the CIA and the FBI
who had a direct line to Twitter and
lost it and were using it to manipulate
narratives but the Tesla and and well
especially SpaceX is like tight with the
Department of Defense they need that
technology and he's helping them and
working isn't he isn't he being sued by
uh Merck Garland or whatever whatever
happened with that he has multiple
lawsuits including some for uh uh going
after him for not hiring enough refugees
in in space for some strange reason the
doj sued him in August for not hiring
refugees despite the fact he's not
legally allowed to they thought they
could control him I really do think they
thought that okay well he's still
somewhat one of us he's not really that
into politics and then they failed and
he's you know fighting back and now
they're starting to realize oh elon's
not on our side I think that they're
really they they've lost their guy they
lost because I think they the the
government likes to control the
wealthiest people in the country and
when they lose them when they start to
lose them that's a threat to them
because they have more power and that's
what's going on here and we kind of saw
it with and this isn't really as big of
a deal because they're not quite as
wealthy as Elon uh but what happened
with the company that made uh sound of
Freedom they came after them the the
whole I think it was rolling stone that
a few other articles came after that too
but they attacked them calling them
kinon and conspiracy theorists and it's
like they this is it's the same thing as
this they they want to make you believe
you can't be successful if you provide a
an perspective outside of the accepted
narrative but um but yeah I think he's a
particular threat because he's so
wealthy and they thought that they could
control him I think they did think they
could re regain control of him so this
is what happens with uh we we we put out
a bunch of songs and uh a lot of things
has happen have happened the first thing
is uh Pete Pata formerly of The
Offspring uh we we make contact with him
we work together we make a song and when
our publicist reached out to various
entertainment Publications to a former
drummer from The Offspring working with
Tim pool the responses we got back were
go f yourself and things like that
Unbecoming of entertainment reporters by
all means they could have been like we
don't like this you know you know we're
not fans of you politically but there's
news there in in what we're doing
instead the response was not only are we
are are like not only are we going to
ignore this to make sure no one knows
you're doing it because we we don't want
to give you any press cuz they View
Press as a weapon they actually emailed
us back we got emails back from variety
of a variety of different entertainment
Al saying F yourselves and we were like
wow when we reached out to I want to
keep it relatively vague for for um
legal reasons litig litigious reasons
when we reached out to various music
industry groups like here's the standard
process by which we publish music they
outright just whoopsie screwed the songs
up screwed up tracking rejected it and
we were just like wow man and so the
original idea we had was to make a song
mocking the whole industry and then when
I saw what Jeremy boring and Michael
nolles did with together again the story
that Jeremy told was they offered a
substantial like 100 times the market
rate to play a song and they were
rejected and so Jeremy was like we're
going to make our own parody version of
this song from the 60s like it's like
basically our version of an Fu and spend
six figures doing it and so that's why
we have the song coming out this Friday
I I don't want to ham it up too much but
I am you know we are promoting it the
issue is
we need to win the culture War the
institutions are controlled the media is
controlled the movie industry is
controlled and so it's not just about
making music it's not just about uh
making movies it's not just about Elon
buying X it's also important to
understand these institutions will spit
in your face publicly will lie about you
outside of the media so this is why
we're doing the best song ever.com this
is why we're making culture and uh it
it's it's all aligned with
the I don't know how to explain it I
guess more than just what people realize
is captured right you you'd think oh the
big labels will only sign B no you don't
understand the financial institutions
Banning people uh uh like web services
cutting people off when uh gab had their
hosting was it gab had their hosting
Seas right it's been it's been a long
time like there there are thin threads
of
infrastructure in in all of these
different networks where people will
give you the middle finger and try and
shut you down
I think that's why music is so powerful
and that writing really good music over
and over and over and just putting out
consistently really good songs is like
not really Unstoppable but pretty close
to Unstoppable with the radio and
shortwave radio like it doesn't require
a lot of bandwidth to get a song across
to somebody um you don't really need
centralized networks and it changes
people and then the people go and they
seek out who did the song and they want
to listen to them and if you're under
five firewalls behind some mesh Network
on some Pirate Radio out at se they're
going to find you and listen to you and
um I think that's the way to do it and
if the messages are in the song and
people don't even realize that's another
way to manipulate the masses into doing
good we are building probably the
largest private East Coast skate
facility for a show and we're spending
several million dollars we're bringing
out pro skateboarders and big uh
industry individuals and we're filming
videos and we're doing it because you
know like every I think everybody who
plays video games everybody who who
likes Sci-Fi movies has seen wokeness
infect their culture and with comic
books and video games it became very
apparent 10 years ago with like
gamergate and for me it's like I play
video games sometimes you know what I
mean I don't really pay attention all
that much so I was like wow this is kind
of crazy here's what's going on then it
came into skateboarding and it's bad and
now I'm like substantially more
irritated and aggressive because it's
attacking something that I participate
in and care about
really really badly I mean the woke
stuff in skateboarding is is just
absolutely getting crazy and uh uh uh we
see it with Taylor Silverman she's a
female athlete and she loses to to males
on more than one occasion and we're
seeing more than just that in
advertising in sponsorships companies no
longer sponsor the best skateboarders
it's it's still there for sure but now
there are people who are getting major
sponsorship deals for identity politics
and I'm like we're going to shut it down
and at least in in terms of what I no
music skateboarding Etc we are going to
invest heavily in pushing back on all
these cultural areas I hope everybody
else does as well so seeing rip averse
Eric jal's comic books is is man the
victories just keep stacking themselves
up so let's make more of those it's it's
almost as if everything is being
weaponized law fair is being weaponized
entertainment is being weaponized movies
are being weaponized and uh the hearts
and minds of individuals especially
during a war are key to win over and and
I think this is the kind of groundwork
we are seeing for what could be
potentially a bigger conflict out there
they are trying to win the hearts and
minds of individuals they're losing look
what happened at Disney the Disney turn
around turn around with with Snow White
the Disney uh uh individuals who of
course are pissed off at the company
which Elon Musk spoke out against
specifically giving a big kind of Fu to
the company and many people on
subscribing from that particular
platform also highlights a big kind of
shift in people's energy and reaction to
towards this as of course everything
woke now is being met with distaste and
and disdain and uh I think it's great a
lot of the people said that Vietnam was
ended because of the musicians of the
time like Crosby Stills naash and young
there was a riot at Kent State 1970 May
4th where all the students were out
yelling and the war and the war and the
they thrown rocks at the National Guard
the National Guard open fire and killed
four kids four four adults at that point
and then Crosby Stills naash young wrote
a song called Ohio about that and it
went hugely popular and it was Al having
the video cameras embedded in the war
zone and seeing the horror that ended it
too but those two things in conjunction
woke the music woke people up seeing it
we're in an age of deep BS now which is
makes things a little strange I I want
to pull up this uh did did you want to
finish no you you finish for me thanks I
want to pull up this uh clip from Tucker
Tucker Carlson episode 49 The Dana White
interview how many of you watched this
okay it's basically just an ad for Bud
Light where Dana White says I'll just
grab a random point at this I'll just
let's just see what happens support
there people like Mexicans support their
people and uh you should be able to walk
in with with with your country's flag so
I brought it back were you under
pressure not to allow it there's always
you know when you deal with consider
myself a proud American I'm happy to be
an American I love this country and you
are way more aligned with anheiser bush
than you are with other beer companies
that I guarantee you have you taken any
crap for it listen people are going to
say what they're going to say I I don't
ever I don't care what people I know who
I am I know what I stand for I know what
I believe in and uh the people who are
close to me know and uh I'm on the right
side of this basically the first few
minutes of this 9-minute clip is Dana
White saying everyone should go out and
buy cases and cases of Bud Light because
they're more aligned with you than you
know and I agree with him I agree with
him I don't know how much he can say to
drive the point home but you have a lot
of people saying no way budlight is dead
to me Etc and you know what I don't
think it matters all that much either
way but I'm on the by Bud Light uh uh
train right now we have Brian kenin says
quote by Bud Light Dana White agrees do
you I think it's silly to judge a
company by one single advertisement
partner they had whether it's the UFC or
Dylan mulany just by products you like
stop trying to cancel every single thing
just because you may may or not 100%
agree with every political ideology they
may have this is one of the greatest
victories you know why the right
boycotted budlight budlight sales tanked
30% budlight desperately tries to win
back the customers they they sponsor
Harley-Davidson doesn't work then they
do a massive deal with UFC and we all
kind of groan like why would UFC do this
and then Shan Strickland comes out and
says budlight has now sponsored
everything I have to say and he said
some things I can't repeat on YouTube
because of the censorship but very uh uh
I would say too many people offensive
though many of these people are offended
by everything and that means budlight
switched from underwriting wokeness to
underwriting anti- woken
there's nothing more you can ask for I
suppose you could ask for an apology but
money has changed hands and there were
people commenting on the Tucker
interview saying what did budlight do
besides changing money changing hands
and I'm like that's exactly it they're
funding a bunch of Bas AF MMA fighters
now and UFC and not Dylan mulany that's
a win individuals like Conor McGregor
who are also becoming more and more
outspoken politically and might even run
to be president of the United States uh
sorry president of Ireland and so now
when Brian kenin says come on everybody
stop boycotting I say here here when the
Liberals don't boycott budlight but the
conservatives do it creates an inverse
pressure the pressure used to be that
conservatives won't boycott but liberals
will so give the Liberals what they want
cuz conservatives will just roll with
the punches but now that conservatives
are boycotting and the Liberals saying
roll with the punches it's going to
create the inverse pressure system where
now companies are going to push in the
opposite direction and cancel the woke
do they have like a $100 million
contract is that what it is so that's
that's a the the company that owns
anheiser bush is a Belgian it's not an
American company Dana just so you know
it's Belgian it's called AB inbev uh
they bought it it's they're worth 15 a
half billion so this Dro in the bucket
of their money I don't see what you're
seeing Tim I I kind of understand the
method specifically yeah but he's like
anheiser bush anheiser bush is owned by
AB inbev which is a Belgian company he
said buy Bud Light M and he was just
saying In that clip that anheiser bush
is the best American company it's the
best most of these other beer I don't
think he said it was American um
companies are that I take it from
somebody who's in the know who does
business with beer companies you are way
more aligned with Bud Light than you are
with I mean they didn't come into
partnership with you by accident no
obviously we had multiple bids on the
table seek you out we had multiple
biders on the table they were one of
them and as I you know history has shown
me with relationships that I've had with
other beer companies I who lean more
this way yeah I who consider myself a
patriot I don't go crazy over the whole
Patriot thing but I consider myself a
proud American I'm happy to be an
American I love this country and you are
way more aligned with anheiser bush than
you are with other beer companies that I
guarantee you have you taken any crap
for it listen people are going to say
what they're going to say I I don't ever
I don't care what people I I I don't
think they were an American company no
well he's talking about patriotism there
and then he he associate it with being
American like you can definitely get
that Vibe even if he doesn't say like oh
it's an American company mhm he uses the
word Patriot and proud American and then
he sells you on a Belgian company that
has no free speech what we want is a
circumstance in which budlight loses
money when they go woke and they make
money when they go anti-woke so that
every single other company will go hey
guys if we if we sponsor woke people
we're going to lose money but if we
sponsor anti-woke people we'll make
money if everybody still boycotts budl
then it it's a win either way because
then come compan are going to say look
don't go woke cuz you lose money but
going conserv doesn't help you either
just don't go woke would you consider
what he just did woke like he just said
I'm a patriot I'm an American so buy a
Belgian beer that's a like what that's
woke as hell like do your research Dana
it's it's a Belgian beer it's not how
does that help American patriotism to
serve the belgians what he he's
encouraging people to buy his Belgium
beer well I'm kind of split on this
because what does that have to do with
anything he used patriotism to sell
people on a foreign beer yeah it's
disingenuous I agree with you that and I
think it would have been yeah I mean I I
I think he clearly wanted you to
associate this beer with America with
patriotism for America and so that's
disingenuous but I'm split on the on the
idea behind it uh what Tim's saying
because it's like on one hand it's yeah
it's kind of a Pavlov's dog situation
where it's like we want to train these
companies to not be woke and therefore
we should reward them when they are no
longer being woke but at the same time
maybe it takes actually putting these
companies out of business to send a
clear message maybe that was the end
maybe that should be the end goal rather
than just to make them suffer a little
bit I don't know I'm not saying that
like you know I I I I see both sides of
you can't put them out of business well
I mean anheiser Bush could subsidize
budlight at infinum so the the best
opportunity is to is to give them the
incentive use the carrot not the stick
so then it goes then the the question
then becomes like to what end would you
boycott them like what's the end goal
that would have to be the decided answer
and then I think you know that you're
economic damage which was 30% sales and
then they gave $100 million to UFC and
at first we all said oh grown we don't
like budlight they got woke they go
broke a lot of people wanted to go to
business and then Sean Strickland came
out and said a whole bunch of things on
Twitter laughing saying budlight
sponsored thank you this message brought
to you by Bud Light we all laughed and
said we went from Dylan Mulaney and in
six months Shan Strickland we like what
St Strickland says so we want budlight
to fund more of what St Strickland says
and then we want every every other
company to see hey guys if we go with
the UFC dudes we're going to make a lot
of money I'm not going to be happy until
there's a can of Sean Strickland with a
do rag presented to the American people
if they do that then maybe I could give
them a chance personally I don't like
alcohol I don't like booze it it it
calcifies your pineal gland it gives you
Bill Gates Ms that's beyond the point
here does it really calcify your pineal
gland a lot of beer is filled with
fluoride and FL there you go okay it's
important to clarify yeah yeah yeah um
but but I I I think the you know I I'm
kind of like in the middle here as well
cuz I understand your point I understand
your point as well here how do we kind
of move forward here I would love to
have an alternative uh company an
American company come out and say hey um
we're we're going to take their we're
going to take their lunch I would rather
that personally myself we have uh Ultra
right conserv conservative dad's Ultra
right beer personally I'm like don't do
anything of the food Seth weathers is
going to be here on the show uh I don't
know I think uh maybe this week or is he
I think it's this week it's this week
and uh and and what he's doing is
fantastic so you know you can check out
his work as well but my point is just
simply it's not about uh destroying it's
like look do you want to raise the enemy
Village or take control of it to utilize
its its labor forces and resources it
depends on the situation certainly and
in this situation you have you you
basically have a village of people who
are all growing crops bowing down to you
saying please please please we'll give
you our we just please stop and instead
it's like you got people saying no no
keep destroying everything that's what
they would do to us they would destroy
us I want their resources I want to take
all of their money and put it towards
Sean Strickland and other based UFC
fighters so they can go on Twitter and
say anti-woke things destroying it
doesn't serve a purpose well I um if
you're talking about see in the metaphor
you've got the people and then you have
the resources and the the people are
Traders and they say please please
please let us join you but they're
treacherous then you might want to
remove the humans from that situation to
take the resources for yourself so there
are other times that you actually let
them serve you the resources is the
human capital and labor then you would
put them in slavery or something like
that this is just military talk of
course that you would enslave the
population and make them work for you if
you TR you just take taxes from them
yeah it depends on how treacherous they
are in military you conquer a city and
you use its resources towards your
military goals in this instance we're
talking about culture War we can see
budlight destroyed or all of that money
they have can go towards anti- woken
initiatives and then we're actually
being armed culturally against the
wokeness I I I have another nuanced
point on this that might be diverting it
a little bit cuz I brought up Bill Gates
moves here and I just remembered Bill
Gates bought a whole bunch of stocks for
aner Bush and uh therefore Tim I totally
disagree with you I am with with Ian
Bill Bill Bill Gates buying public stock
to try and destroy the company makes
sense to help Bill Gates and to help
wokeness he wants to make sure no one
gets behind the company and they can't
recover for this reason he's basically
saying scorched Earth if they claim Bud
Light then we are going to lose
Resources by buying into it he's going
to get people like you to refuse to
support the company that is funding UFC
anti-woke uh uh personalities I did some
numbers earlier the revenue of anheiser
Bush was 15 A5 billion in 2018 15 and a
half the revenue of its parent company
was 52 billion so 15 52 in 2019 anheiser
bush is a skin suit it's not a real
company it's owned by a Belgian company
called anheiser Bush 52 billion in
income in Revenue in 2019 so unless they
put like six seven billion towards this
stuff that we that we like I'm not going
to start to think they really care at
all I think this is a I don't think they
care this is just publicity St of course
and it doesn't matter woke uh uh
leftists have captured the institutions
and the argument from the right is to
sacrifice the institutions instead of
reclaiming them that makes no sense the
goal should be to reclaim and control
all of the cultural institutions so that
we can then indoctrinate young people to
American values um some of the
institutions need to fail I think some
need that's what I I think too that's
kind of why I'm in more of like the let
them suffer and like they would do that
to us like they they they want to
destroy us they want to destroy
everything and so if it was like a
patriotic company and this was happening
they'd be like no keep pushing them
don't buy anything from them they made
that's what that's why we're like
whenever they cancel us they have no
forgiveness they have no Grace
whatsoever and it's like why would we
extend that to them don't they we're not
extending it to them you're like say
it's it's like saying quick burn down
our own bridge that we've reclaimed
because they would have burned it down
too why we need the bridge why not if
you're we're going to build culture why
are we just going to destroy all of what
they have built if we can't just take it
for ourselves and use it ourselves why
wouldn't we do that it makes no sense to
get rid of
it imagine the the One Ring you know
budlight is
not budlight is a factory you have woke
forces and anti-woke forces woke forces
have taken over the factory as of the
past few months the anti-woke forces
have reclaimed the servitude of the
factory and now the argument is quick
burn the factory down why we have it
it's ours we we get it all because I
don't well a reason why the the
anti-woke MMA fighters are getting paid
more money UFC is getting funded this
means the public will recognize the
statements made by these Fighters are
funded by Bud Light you have lost this
cultural battle except if the factory if
you're like now that's our Factory but
who was in that factory running that
factory and who are their financial ties
behind the scenes that I don't know so
if I really want to leave that Factory
up and running what's the risk yeah I
mean the UFC is one of the most popular
uh Sports Industries in the entire world
they're not going to have problems
they're financing one of the biggest
kind of uh Sports uh franchises in the
entire world so what are they investing
in I I think that's a question that we
should be asking ourselves because they
will do anything for a buck they tried
to sell tweens and small children
alcohol by advertising with Dylan
malvaney is that something that is
excusable that depends is this something
that we should be fighting for I don't
know let the let the audience decide if
if you think that we should be taking
over the bridge uh press one in the
comment section if you think we should
be of course punishing the the woke
bridge that tried to sell alcohol to
Children press number two in the
comments so the issue would be like if
you have a government that rules with an
iron fist eventually you will get revolt
and collapse but if you rule through
incentives and goals you will have
people enthusiastically supporting you
if if the anti-woke forces in the
culture culture War send the message to
big companies no matter what you do
there is no coming back and we will
destroy you you the response is going to
be okay well then we'll go woke because
they'll at least give us money but I
think it's exhausting to do a boycott
and it took the Bud Light That Bud Light
boycott was like a four-month thing
three-month thing to really and it to
change get people into the mindset of
I'm done with that crap Bud Light I'm
done with it I'm done with it now to get
them back into it doesn't sound good it
sounds like you're going in reverse
while you're going 80 on the highway and
it's going to do more confusion damage
than worth it I think boycotting this
company's The Right Move um it's just a
multinational billion dollar alcohol
will say this 30% sales are written off
completely stay the course and keep
putting out uh Pride ads right they need
like an off-ramp they need a place to go
you can't just tell the woke you're
doing it wrong you have a wrong way to
go and then not give them a chance to
say hey here's a better way here's the
way we the way forward you can't just
tell them you know you know that's what
they're saying To Us by by canceling as
you as us they spent $100 million trying
to save themselves that's like next to
nothing though compared to what they're
worth $100 million to save themselves
it's the biggest deal in UFC history
it's one 500th of their revenue that has
nothing to do with the UFC getting the
biggest deal in history the biggest deal
in history can I go for it and the
response from the anti-woke is there is
no recovery you are guaranteeing that
the only thing budlight will do is say
then how can we how can we get more beer
from the left we have nothing nothing to
give the right so cut them off and never
even try anymore it's like an abusive
husband trying to come back please take
us back like dude you screwed us like
this company's been screwing the the pop
I this is why the right loses this is
why the right has lost for so long
because the left marched through the
institutions and they said now we have
the New York Times now we will use this
to Crush free speech and the right goes
let's just tear it all down I tell you
if Elon Musk buys ABN Bev I'm on board
sorry an were you going to say something
no I was just going to say that I I I
kind of agree with you I think that
there needs to be some EX example of
like what happens like I'm not saying
that needs to be the the approach every
single time a company goes woke but I
think we need a couple examples of like
hey you will go out of business if this
is the case or you will suffer to a
point where this particular product is
not even something people want to buy in
this country anymore I think yeah we
sent them sort of a message but I don't
really think it
was I don't I I think that it needed to
go it needs to go further I do think
that you know as far as we need to use
your resources we don't really we could
just use we could just fund other beer
companies there are other beer companies
we don't really need budlight to Bud
Light if that is the course taken we'll
start giving more money to woke
initiatives yeah they will fund more
Pride events they will fund more Pride
commercials and the right will be like
why why why are they doing this oh no
well it's because you told them screw
off but then we will continue to not buy
it but they're not dying because of it
and all that will do is give the woke
forces money yeah you need budlight to
commit 100% of their resources to
anti-woke
right right now they've lost 30% they've
lost 30% in sales we can tell them hey
we'll give you we'll give you that 30%
back if you allocate your funding in our
Direction and they're and they're saying
hm that sounds like it might work let's
try let's give UFC $100 million and
you've got people still saying it'll
never be good enough they go ah screw it
that $100 million we're going to spend
on UFC give it to Dylan Mulaney yeah do
is that what you want because if if
these 30% of people never come back to
budlight they'll just give more money to
Dylan wania congratulations I mean then
you'll get more Pride events or the
inverse of it because they could say oh
you know budlight could get away with
this they could advertise their small
children they could advertise Dylan
mulany but if they just you know give a
little bit money to the UFC they're
going to be cleared of all wrongdoing
and therefore uh you know why why not
why not get away with don't do it again
we'll lose the money the business guys
are right now looking at their bottom
line and they're saying we lost 30% how
do we get it back we've got to get away
from wokeness before Dylan mulany we
were at x amount of sales after Dylan
mulany we're at xus 30% to recover the
30% we need to get away from wokeness
and go towards something that's not woke
if they give money to UFC and it works
they're going to say never spend money
on that stuff again well I think we say
no you can never recover they're going
to say we're at xus 30 we can't recover
that 30% stay the course and at least
we'll maintain the pride Community they
have like no other choice at that point
they want to fail as a company then they
would then they would be like okay well
well I guess we're done I guess we're I
guess we canel we quit if the investment
caused a huge 30% loss why do you think
that they would continue that train of
investment because they've already lost
at 30% there's no negative and there's
no positive there's only negative no
there isn't they've already lost 30% and
then they stopped doing it and they so
now they're saying we've got people who
are angry at us who are on the left but
the right won't forgive us at all ever
so there's no point in trying to recover
that Revenue let's go back to the to the
pride events and see if we can at least
maintain that market that's like a I
kind of want more from
them I want more from Bud Light I I I
want them to do more to show us that
they're changing yeah exactly give us
some cultural reparations here host an
Irish lives matter protest in Ireland
let's do something like that let's let's
have Sean Strickland with the durag on
the can I want it I would I would then
go out there and buy it I think we need
just a little bit more from my
perspective but I I might be asking too
much doing is too much of a a wink wink
nudge nudge to the right like oh we're
on your side guys but we're still kind
of in the left's camp maybe if they a
little further yeah I agree
more ad it's a Belgian company that
wants in the United States to fail man
it's just part of this International
banking I'm listening to people who
chess being like don't control the
center of the board it's pointless they
wouldn't let us control it so why should
we get either and I'm like what yeah
there are some take the money let's get
that Center out of the game so that we
can play on more equal ground you cannot
we can boycott companies to death like
imagine a great General being like don't
take the field because they wouldn't let
us take it either way so we should run
the other direction okay if let the W
take all the institutions let him take
the iers ities let them take the
television networks and then cross your
fingers that Ultra right conservatives
beer can rival the multi-billion dollar
beer brand and cross your fingers that
Jeremy Jeremy's razors and Jeremy's
chocolates is going to beat Hershey's
that's absolutely fine more power to you
I just think if you have the op option
of occupying a major Factory with
billions of dollars and utilizing all of
its resources to your end you need to
push that in your direction may maybe
maybe the universities maybe the the
media organizations need to fail yeah
that's my perspective I the universities
with with how much Injustice they caused
which how much servitude and debt they
caused American which how much just woke
nonsense and poison that they have put
into America let them fail that's
they're not really reparable in my
opinion like they need to fail and maybe
we build something else but like it's
not I think I agree at this point like
they're just I don't know if it's we're
at a point where we can fix it even yeah
it's everything's coming to a head like
they said war they're planning an
October war with Russ they're like it's
no time to joke around right now the
companies that are are wrecking the
American way of life need to fail I feel
that but I I think your point about it
being not even American-owned that's an
important point I don't think it makes
it woke but I do think it begs the
question why are they advertising it as
they want us to associate it with you
know American patriotism I think that is
an important part of it what what are we
why are we mad at
budlight they tried to sell alcohol to
children and culturally promoted uh the
larger ideology that Dylan mven
represents and so what would make us not
mad at budlight nothing
never ads jeez if if they started I I I
I had my things what I wanted I've got
personal like Investments they could
start going with into like graphing Tech
and like high tech like revolutionary
energy technology can I really do I want
more I want represent I want them to say
we made a mistake we're going to fix it
this is us standing uh by something new
in the culture War we're going to be
we're going to have just as big of an
impact like we did with Dylan Moi we're
going to have it bigger on the other
side
$10,000 they gave UFC 100 million yeah
like if you can't accept that as a
victory you will lose cuz they lost
money for 6 months 30% they they want
you to think it's a victory it cost them
nothing relatively nothing W 500th of
their 2019 Revenue it revenue is not
profit what's their profit uh operating
income to net income geez their total
assets are 236 billion what's their
profit all it doesn't say we're revenue
is not profit their margins could be 3%
for all we know their operating income
16 and a half billion right and so
what's their profit yeah you had margin
uh the net the net income n billion no
we need their profit their margins
because for the for a beer company
shipping liquids I imagine their margins
are going to be relatively small but
they're still probably making billions
but it's a question of like how much
money are they generating and and that's
and it's not even the question the
question is this what is Victory
seriously what what is your condition of
Victory if if uh woke institutions say
okay you win we're going to fund 10,000
times more money towards you and you go
no it's like okay well then you you have
no win condition what's your win
condition but if it's like 10,000 times
more for you but it's 1500th less for
them you got to do that that opportunity
cost and if it costs them next to
nothing to give you a 5,000% boost you
got to see is it really costing them
anything at all to make me think I'm
gaining something well I I mean honest
question guys what's your win condition
they fail they lose the the the
establishment uh just stops operating in
a in a hurtful way the universities get
shut down the corporate media get shut
down and people talking about bu
light I just think what's the win
condition bu light to be so obviously
patriotic in order for them to have any
hope of of us like accepting them again
and and I don't I don't think this is
enough I think this is just some guy
being paid to say something that isn't
even true like the fact that it's such a
patriotic beer and then in addition to
that I think that if that they're not
going to meet that expectation which
they won't then yeah I I think we let
them fail we let them fail on this I got
a win condition but light won't go out
of bus anheiser Bush loses so much money
that they shutter it and Seth weathers
buys it okay well that's not going to
happen well well gez it yes it is what
that's my wind condition is it their
sales drop has sted at 30% and it
stabilized well let's shut it down sell
it to sell to an American company get it
back make it American again if the
people who already stopped buying it
stopped buying it how how do you make
their sales drop more people to stop
buying it I wanted to be an American
company again that's my wind condition
anheiser bush is an American company
okay now now my question is how do you
get Bud like to be sold to an American
company you got to boycott it basically
okay that's already happened what's next
keep the boycott going right so they've
so they've been out for for uh uh 75% of
the year at around averaging around 28
to 30% sales drop off what's the next
play uh you would have to just continue
doing I mean it would be exhausting to
like go after one multinational company
and try and bankrupt it are are you
saying that like after a year of minus
30% sales a stable stabilized sales base
they will eventually just say you know
we're going to sell the product well we
don't really owe them anything so like
if we just don't want to buy it because
they don't represent what we believe in
then we just will continue not to not
buy it you know even if it doesn't put
them out of business per se so the issue
is wi condition is irrelevant you just
don't want to buy Bud
Light I was really pissed off when they
gave Dylan mulany a commercial to sell
beer to his audience which was like 17
year olds and stuff or young young it
was 15 to 16 year old and that's like a
beer company selling to that guy to
having to sell his audience that was
really gross to me like a total
mismanagement like are they trying to
poison our populace I know that they're
set send people are sending fentanyl up
across the southern border like what are
they doing with Dylan Mulan and alcohol
well just alcohol in general is a very
net negative uh for your brain and for
your health but but that's not talking
about the conversation Tim brings up
some good points that are worth
considering uh for me again I'm just
going to reiterate maybe I'm not maybe
it's not the Strategic maybe it's not
the smartest move but but I do think
culturally a lot of what the
corporations do matters and if they're
trying to appease the ESG social credit
scorer uh CLA rild Pope connected
revisionist of capitalist individuals if
if they're trying to do that they
deserve to fail in my opinion got it we
boycott UFC next some people have said
that then that's the move we make right
now and we give Dana White the middle
finger because if Dana White is going to
accept Bud Light and you guys won't then
we must now condemn UFC Shan Strickland
Dana White and any single one of them
who advocated for defending I thought it
was a total sellout on Dana's Park I
agree and Sean Strickland I want you
guys like we got we got to call them all
out that's if Sean Strickland comes out
and says Bud light's being rehabilitated
by me and you guys are saying no it's
not then we call him out too boycott him
don't he just fought the other night no
no did he fight recently no Sean
strickling yeah he fought a couple weeks
he became champion of the he's going to
be fighting soon I like him don't watch
it I really like him I like you cannot
you cannot simultaneously condemn Bud
Light but then defend the people who are
defending Bud Light well I agree I agree
that's I I I actually think this is
totally fake this whole UFC thing this
oh we're going to support Bud Light now
I don't like it I think that it's uh he
and and I I don't like the way like and
I never picked up on this before you
pointed it out but like the way he wants
us to associate supporting Bud Light
with patriotism like that's just slimy
especially when it's not owned by an
American company so I I actually agree I
think you're right I would do the same
the next move is we boycot for everybody
who thinks budlight should not be
rehabilitated we have to call out Dana
White we have to boycott UFC we have to
call out any UFC personality supported
this and refuse to watch or purchase any
or tickets to their fights and demand
that Shawn and any other UFC fighter
refus to participate in UFC until until
they cancel their sponsorship with I do
Wonder though and I I don't know maybe
maybe it's true but did UFC specifically
make a deal with them or was it just the
fighters okay and then came out saying
that he was going to save budlight
because he said a whole bunch of
anti-woke stuff on Twitter and said
brought to you by Bud Light if that is
unacceptable then we need to call out
anybody who's standing alongside I
actually think that's a fair thing I
think that to stay consistent I think
that is fair and I think that I would
support that well right on so how many
so are you guys in favor of boycotting
UFC I don't watch UFC anyway I do like
watching guys fight because it's a cool
sport L you won't do it but the uh the
sellout Dana White I'm thinking about it
I like watching the UFC that's right
being honest it's easy for you to
boycott Bud Light you don't drink
alcohol is it easy for you to boycott
the UFC are youing I mean Dana Dana sold
his ID he he said patriotism patriotism
by Belgian company and it's like yo Dana
that ain't American so maybe he just
wanted the money 100 million bucks he's
going to keep the company solvent for
another three years or whatever the hell
and he wants to sign another deal with
him later that's why he's talking so
highly of him right now it's easy to
boycott a product you never bought in
the first place that's fair I don't
really watch UFC so it's hard for me to
say that like and Luke's a big UFC fan
but are you going to support UFC after
they just that's I thought about that I
I I I heard Dana White's arguments and I
heard this endorsement and it it kind of
rubbed me the wrong way I was like it
kind of does seem like you know profit
is a little bit more important than the
kind of culture War here uh that was my
initial reaction from it am I wrong I I
could be I'm not always right I'm I'm
not always you know perfect myself I at
first said Shan Strickland was wrong
Dana White was selling out and then I
actually listened to what Shan
Strickland was saying and I realized he
was right that this is a major win but
if that is unacceptable and I'm wrong
then we cannot just accept that UFC took
$100 million from a corporation that has
no intention of actually standing up for
our values and we cannot allow that that
would mean Dana White's a Trader a
sellout and that means all of these UFC
fighters are getting are willing to
fight in the ring with the budlight logo
don't care about our values either you
know I'm not too worried about
international business it's it's not my
my fight I don't like that they sold
beer to the a child Market through Dylan
malany that was like over the line but
I'm not I I don't necessarily want to go
after every multinational corporation
just CU they're multinational
corporations and they get into ESG like
like you said there are there are I
there just always so much mind Focus
that one can do and to to do a a
constant boycott of like every company
that touches every company I don't like
I don't like that doing that kind of
thing well I I I don't see the logic in
saying budlight can never recover but
we're absolutely on board with companies
colluding with these with these these
unrecoverable companies like when when
when UFC first announced this major deal
with Bud Light the immediate reaction
was boycott UFC and that's what
everybody was
saying let's let's go to super chats if
you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
head over to
timcast.net because Bill Mah triggered a
woke activist talking about uh
transgender issues and I think we should
break this down so uh before all that
we'll re what y'all have to say Clint
Torres wins first place he got the first
Super Chat saying howdy people howdy
howdy with a little waving emoji and a
cowboy man all right Andrew and Andrew D
843 says Congress said they didn't have
9.7 billion over 10 years to fund the
major Richard star act but can send 75
billion plus to Ukraine this year over
50,000 troops who got injured in combat
and medically retired don't get
retirement to this day and that's why we
all hate Congress yeah cuz that is
corruption right there yeah money for
what is they got money for the war but
they can't feed the poor who said that
what was that quote that's a good line I
don't know who said that but it was
something like like was it Tupac lose
yelling it from I can't hear him Luke
knew L yelling it from the bathroom I
can't hear him he y
Tupac was it what did he say Joe
Mitchell Jo was the first name that came
up I couldn't he's yelling from the oh
yeah there's Tupac thanks Luke
all right here we go Raymond g Stanley
Jr says not know that Tupac quote Tupac
quote Tim I I knew the quote I just
didn't know was him Tim it's
indisputable that the line is being is
being forwarded culturally and
politically there's been too many recent
positives to not see the line moving I
completely agree Mike cernovich had a
great tweet he said imagine going to
2020 and claiming that three of the
presidents of Harvard pen and MIT were
facing removal for anti-Semitism and
that Alex Jones had been brought back to
to uh to a to Twitter which is now
called X you'd be 5150 great Point
brilliant Point too cuz he like he's
absolutely correct on that Jacob parody
says just saw the shift over the weekend
highly recommend if you don't know
already Sean Aston gives one of the best
lines so far quote I'm always packing
well all
right codex says sign up for X today
just to have my account vanish on
logging out right after I paid for
premium X support sent an auto message
saying can't verify the account doesn't
exist man Elon makes it hard to support
Free Speech well you got to understand
Twitter was a disgusting sinking ship
and Elon has been working tirelessly to
try and fix it I will say unfortunately
however and we'll get into this in the
members only grock is woke oh yeah you
super woke you you've been testing it
dude grock is so woke you yeah yeah you
will so we'll say this for the members
only but yeah I've been testing out
grock which is Twitter's large language
model we call him AI I guess and if you
ask it a question a fact-based question
it won't give you the answer it'll give
you a non answer related to some woke
issue oh no that's not good for the
future of AI we know it's all going to
be woke but I I'll show you exactly what
I mean if you look at my Twitter you can
see it but I'll save it for the members
only people are saying I just did a
Vivic a Vivic your mic wasn't hot good I
it sounded like he was making espresso
or something I think it was a sink that
was on yeah that's what it sounded like
he could have peed and then washed his
hands both could be true and sometimes
you I listen to it and I'm like yeah
okay it I got to be honest if that was
urinating VI's got a seriously damaged
and enlarged prostate and he's having
trouble urinating like that doesn't
sound like a man going the bathroom
especially a
38-year-old it sounded like he was
making a coffee or an espresso or
something I don't know whatever I don't
know I don't know whatever all right all
right let's read some more uh super
chats what do we have here waffle Sensei
says funny how they told us to build our
own platforms to share our opinions now
they team up with the government to try
and destroy those platforms sounds like
they did that with
parlor I I'm willing to bet government
was in the government was involved in
getting parlor taken
down Buster Ruckus says are we not going
to talk about the black woman who tried
to burn down MLK's house we all know who
the media would blame if she hadn't been
caught that's a crazy story I don't know
enough about it though but yeah there
was like some black woman was caught
trying to burn down Martin Luther King's
Junior's house your off I saying you met
a wife supremacist I mean they'll call
her that I guess yeah they will what is
it Larry Elder
Kyle Beckham says there is a
mobilization happening I have it from
Navy buddies that deployment will occur
in August to the Pacific interesting I'm
hearing a lot about that too but it's
hard to discern if it's true or not that
Panama Canal that a lot of troops are
being called up interesting
Panama over Venezuela no no no I mean
Venezuela also there's another War there
Brewing as well the Panama Canal is
super valuable though it's like the Suez
there's it's just so important to have
control that thing where we at uh Paul
tascal says SNL irony fired Shane Gillis
in 2019 for an offensive joke Shane is
currently one of the most successful
standup comedians and sketch actors SNL
now making toned deaf unfunny offensive
garbage get woke go broke I correct you
there Paul you you made a mistake it's
get woke go broke as it's been for 10
years but uh yeah SNL have did you guys
watch that uh opening I couldn't even
finish it I could could get finish it
but I did hear a little bit of it it
wasn't funny in anyway and the weirdest
thing is they attacked Alise
stonic and they added things that were
not part of the hearing it was clear
they were not engaged in making jokes
Alise stonic said is it a violation of
your rules to call for the genocide of
Jews in the SNL version she goes
an and it's like what and then the woman
then the president of one of the
organizations goes like we try to limit
hate speech against all students
including Jewish students Muslim
Students and then Alisa FICO nope nope
nope not that one not that one and I'm
like I don't understand what the joke is
cuz Alis aonic in no way insulted
Muslims M yeah they're just trying to to
this is what they did when Tina Fay made
fun of Sarah Palin and said I can see
Russia from my house and then liberals
all believed Sarah Palin actually said
that oh yeah yeah Sarah Palin actually
said when it comes to negotiating with
Russia we actually do negotiate every
year because of the bearing straight
because we have ships moving through uh
territorial Waters and interestingly in
the western most point of Alaska you can
actually see with the naked eye Russia
so as these ships are coming through BL
like a very articulate and composed
statement about international relations
in order to discredit her as a
politician Tina Fay says something dumb
and then people think Sarah Palin
actually
said figured out where the joke is the
joke's on Lauren Michaels that show
sucks Lauren it's time to pack it in man
or sell it or something yeah that was
get a better
cast is he still around yeah he kicking
it
man all right let's grab some more voice
of the people says Luke is right my
account was nuked on YouTube for asking
questions about the jab I'm picking up
slowly on Rumble with listening to the
Senate and committee hearings it's wild
what what they say themselves yeah yeah
they tried to destroy Independent Media
and they were ruthless with it the
smaller creators I think had a bigger
impact than some of the bigger guys that
got hit because that really changed uh
the people who would be big players now
that are that are not and that was the
big thing with um uh Twitter censorship
going back several years they'd make
arguments like we we didn't ban
conservatives and that was a mistake and
they were restored ah but what was
happening was they they rolled out an
algorithm on Twitter back in the day
where it was Banning anybody who said
hashlearn to code unless you were on a
white list that's why when I tweeted
hashlearn to code nothing bad happened
but that's why when the
editor-in-chief of I think it was the
Daily Caller tweeted it he got banned
and they went whoops that was an
accident sorry about that that wasn't
supposed to happen the only issue all
the small accounts who tweeted it got
banned and they had no Advocates and no
PR and were unable to actually get their
accounts restored so they were getting
rid of all of the of the grassroot
sentiment opposed to the media
industry that's how they did it it's
like the movie Scream like the group's
all walk in then one guy gets yanked
from behind and they're they just keep
walking they don't they don't know
what's happening that kind of thing yeah
it is sneaky yeah purple says what is
scnr switching it up with no explanation
you know this is one of the bigger
challenges with any show uh good sir
purple if you watched every episode of
timcast IRL you'd know exactly what scnr
was but the issue is I think on average
a person will watch between 2.5 to six I
I say that it's wide range because
different platforms have different
metrics on uh audio versions it's like
two and a half podcasts per person and
then uh a little bit more maybe it's
like three and then on YouTube YouTube
it's like s or eight so if you skip an
episode you're going to be like what's
this well you know to be continued you
got to go back and watch all the old
episodes which you know is not
reasonable put them all at the same time
it's a you know it is funny there was
this woman who wrote this uh fake
academic study where she it was called
the alternative influencer Network or
something where she claimed that a bunch
of like anti-establishment YouTubers
were all secretly connected and she
connected Chris rayun who does like
video game content to Richard Spencer
these two guys who have never met before
and so she got roasted for it and then I
guess because of that she she did a a
research paper on me specifically where
she said she watched all of my content
and I gotta be honest I was flattered
and I was like yo that's like six it at
the time it was four hours of content
Monday through Friday and two hours
Saturday and Sunday because this was
back in uh what was this 2020 when I was
doing uh weekends with I was Zero days
off weekends I would record until like 3
and then Monday through Friday was three
and then also IRL and she actually wrote
a paper saying she had watched every
single one of my videos and bat catalog
and then she was like he's
liberal I'm like wow think about how
like mentally unwell you'd have to be to
watch every Tim poool video ever there's
a lot of people out there being like uh
I think she wants to date you I like you
oh man you know good for her though it's
like wow that that means she had to have
watched in order like I was tracking
from when she finished the the Articles
like a couple years after I was like
that means she had to have watched three
days of my contact content every day
Monday to Sunday nonstop maybe she had
them at twoo speed I got to be honest it
all but no but two time speed sure but
she still to watch three days worth of
content it could also be she's
lying how about that it's aam's Razer at
work yeah slicing the truth in half the
these Shady individuals connected to
indel agencies and George Soros don't
lie Gustavo Gutierrez says I Venezuela
and want to clarify a factor regarding
ESO Zona de reclam the land was
Venezuelan from the get-go I do not
agree with how Maduro is going about the
reclaim of the land please read the
history very interesting it's true
there's a big fight Brewing there that
and even even Google's long had a dotted
line for the Border it's been disputed
yeah I do but it is kind of funny that
they're like hey there's oil here and
then M's like we should reclaim our land
mhm oh there's value there now and you
know it's a good reason for us to go
in let's grab some more uh legma says I
disagree about Bud Light corporations
must understand going woke will be their
end they must perceive it as an
unacceptable risk that nobody dares to
bring up in boardrooms for fear of being
fired this is how we crush the woke
without Baloo so there's another way of
U of looking at it we want companies of
their own valtion to invest in anti-woke
initiatives we don't want neutrality we
want to win so the message should be get
anti-woke make lots of money that's it
if the message is enter politics in any
fashion and you lose it's it's it's it's
still a win you know because companies
will just be like I don't want to get
political but we'd win faster if
companies were like hey sponsor more
anti-woke channels it's tough with these
big public companies because V vard and
black rock and State Street are so
heavily across the board but like
private companies can twist and turn a
lot easier like so sometimes it's better
for one big woke company to fail and a
new one to start up than it is to try
and change that big Behemoth of an
organization there uh Andrew says hey
Tim and cast the Obamas produced a film
called Leave the World Behind which
showcases the breakdown of society
during a Cyber attack thoughts there's
also a scene going viral where a woman
says don't trust white people I don't
know what that's all about but you know
it's in the movie whatever that means B
white people context is important
because I I doubt it but for all we know
she's not a good guy in the film you
know she's saying things like I'm racist
blah blah blah and then they're like
showing her saying that but I'm I'm
assuming the assumption is she's just
you know being woke yeah yeah and it's a
woke film I I watched the trailer it
definitely seems like a very woke film
that the Obama produced we've said the
word woke so many times in the last
three minutes it's so funny project
Editon says just make Bud Light the 5
first state yes well there you go
problem solved oh corporations are
States now as well as people that's an
Ian argument
[Laughter]
what do we got here Michael Jackson the
Michael Jackson says do y'all really
think Dana doesn't have a cancel Clause
then Dana's hardcore against Bud Light
it's a possible lose lose for budlight
so then if the point is budlight can
never recover we have to force UFC into
cancelling their their their budlight
contract the biggest victory over
budlight would be if if you want it to
be a nuclear bomb in terms of budlight
sales having UFC break their contract
and kick them out would be the most
devastating defeat budlight that would
be awesome and you should have Dana
White on the culture war that would be
awesome to defend why he did that that
would be so cool cuz he he might have a
good reason for taking the 100 million
there might be more to it I mean
obviously yeah he's got 100 million
reasons but but but if that's not enough
and uh uh that you have to to boycott
UFC the only problem is I don't think
you can boycott UFC I don't think the
fans will boycott UFC and UFC did not do
anything as egregious as budlight
they've simply aligned themselves with
budlight so you can accept Shan
Strickland going anti-woke and taking
budlight money and taking claiming
sticking his flag in the budlight
factory or you can say no we reject this
you're collaborating with the Enemy and
tell Sean Strickland no we we don't
accept what you're saying Dana White
you've sold out UFC be gone yeah I mean
I think that it's mostly in theory the
argument I I don't think people would
actually boycott UFC I I think it's what
would need to happen to make the point
but I don't think any I I don't think it
would it would be on enough of a grand
scale people just like especially
conservatives they like UFC too much I
think Luke's silently breathing a sigh
of relief as you said that Raymond g
Stanley Jor says I gotta say the whole
Bud Light convo is fantastic do you get
uh do you uh do you get hold the line or
forward it hold it with boycott or
forward it by using honey for
bees Eric Max says Tim is right the more
money for the anti woke the better yeah
frog boogers says budlight never
apologized hold them accountable
supporting them again gives them an
opportunity to just sweep what they've
done under the rug that's so uh don't
don't ever buy Hugo Boss or Volkswagen
either for real because they serve the
Nazis yeah absolutely IBM but but I mean
seriously yeah IBM no no question don't
buy any IBM computer parts or IBM
machines uh go Mac you know oh wait
no Mac used the foxcon labs were all
those people who are Marching off the
roofs in suicide okay um you ever see
ancient Technologies on YouTube no where
the guy like builds cool stuff from like
mud pools and stuff oh this life awaits
you and I'm I I don't mean that I'm only
half kidding it looks so awesome and fun
to like you ever see those guys they
build a swimming pool are those two
Indian guys yeah yeah I've seen those
come on that stuff's awesome it turns
out though they had machines behind the
scenes are fake real some yeah that is
disappointing you think they did that
with little little hand trials and stuff
like that in that
time okay I was told that they have fake
it's fake but I could be it could be
wrong there could be people that do it
for real there could be that's that's a
good point it could be both things
that's a good point waffle Sensei says
the action of going anti-woke is more
important than the apology I want to win
Sam T says people who are calling for
Bud to go down clearly never had a dog
you encourage good behavior and
discourage bad behavior simple anyone
with Intel stats over three will figure
that one out yeah but they're using math
there's no dog to entice in this
situation it's all mathematics and
machine algorithm work so like you've
got to just play the numbers on this one
logic plague says wokeness has infected
something we all love at some point I'd
rather see those things reclaimed than
destroyed yeah yeah like we're re we're
retaking the ground we've lost the
ground why aren't we retaking it we
should be happy that we're retaking it
that's that's the way I see it Mr Big
says Tim's argument is baseless Twitter
X isn't real nothing has changed at bu
light except Tim's attitude towards it
budlight execs are laughing uh no my
attitude was Sean Strickland is wrong
and Dana White sold out and then Shan
Strickland made a bunch of statements on
Twitter under the banner of budlight and
budlight said nothing and I was like
whoa budlight wouldn't even dare
denounce the things said by St Sean
Strickland and he claimed it was
sponsored by them and I'm like that's it
they are cowering right now but if you'd
rather see them destroyed then by all
means you have to stop collaborator
you have to boycot the
collaborators I I don't see I I don't
see anything other than hypocrisy for
the people who are like well I'll keep
watching UFC but I don't like Bud Light
why no I agree with that I I just think
in theory like it makes sense but like
on a mass scale it wouldn't be effective
enough and also there's always going to
be a conservative that will sign on to
some sort of deal like that because it
is so much money like even if you were
to boycott UFC it's going to be somebody
else who's going to endorse them and and
you know whether or not that's going to
be effective enough to get people to buy
the beer again I don't know but I don't
I there's just always going to be
somebody who's willing to do anything
for money nobody's going to boycott UFC
yeah I don't I don't I don't think so
either so so so if if the statement is
we're still mad at you Bud Light but we
won't boycott UFC now they're laughing
no I and budl saying we got you by the
balls we know you're not willing to
boycott UFC so we can give them money we
can win and y'all won't do anything
about it so you can take the pr Victory
and say we've won and Bo and budlight
has caved to give us their money or you
can say you're right we can't stand up
for our convictions we will not condemn
UFC we will not condemn these Fighters
and that's it budlight
wins I think they're they only care if
they make money so we're going to see if
people sales have not recovered no they
not if if they buy it if they don't I
think that's going to be the big tell
here as as of the latest report which is
is into December I believe they sales
are still down year-over-year for by 30%
which means 30 so it's not dropping
every month by 30% more it means that
December 2023 sales compared to December
2022 sales they've seen a decline of 30%
that means they've stabilized 30%
boycotted Bud Light over over Dylan
mulany and their sales have stabilized
at this number and not changed in fact
it's fluctuated a little bit up and down
well from 22 to 23 they're down 30 are
they in a downward trajectory like are
they projected they are not they're
stable budlight sales are stable at 70%
of their previous number so every time
they say sales this month are down 30%
they don't mean month to month that
indicates that the people that were
triggered by the Dylan Mia event have
already done the bo they've boycotted
and the PE everyone else just wasn't
necessarily triggered by it right and so
what's going to happen is by April uh
when was the boyot May is what it
started by May of next year Bud light's
going to show uh that their sales have
recovered and they're going to say sales
have gone from so it's what's going to
start happening is once they get to the
beginning of May they're going to say
sales are now down 20% sales are now
down 15 sales are now down seven sales
are now down N9 and the media is going
to report and mass budlight sees massive
recovery and what may end up happening
at that time is that right before that
happens budlight will do something sort
of woke and then when the sales start
recovering because they're not really
recovering it's just that month
year-over-year sales will are stable
that means the percentages will look
will go to zero they'll claim we our
sales recovered from 30% losses by doing
this campaign and they can make that
campaign whatever they want it to be and
that'll be the the pr narrative so
either you guys defeat budlight 100% And
they lose completely before May of next
year or you force UFC fighters to say a
whole bunch of shockingly anti-woke
things and you force budlight to answer
for it yeah that's way more fun Dana
what he would would he fire the fighters
if they started sand talking about Bud
Light nasty the sponsors are like well
Sean Strickland already did he said
nasty speech brought to you by budlight
and then said things I can't say on
YouTube oh awesome and budlight did
nothing about it I mean that's crazy
you've got celebrities that fart and
then issue apologies you know what I
mean and here you've got a UFC fighter a
champion saying this stuff and like
budlight does nothing about it but but
but regardless ignore my opinion
understand this once we get
year-over-year into May they're going to
compare maze sales of let's just let's
just say 100
units let's just use generic units
budlight sales we at 100 boycott hits
they go to 70 every month after that
they're they're selling they're selling
70 units so the metric they're reporting
in the Press is minus 30% minus 30%
minus 30% once they get to next May
they're going to say this may we sold 70
units and last may we sold 70 units our
sales are at 0% 0% growth and now
they're going to say we've recovered
we're back baby 70 is The New Normal
exactly yeah but they shut down 30% of
their production capacity or something
if some of the sales come back for any
reason they're going to say we're now up
their stock will start to recover their
sales will start to recover so the issue
is going to be what move can you make
right now to prevent that narrative from
happening because now your chance you
got five months if it went okay so it's
down 30% that would mean if you can
knock it down another
15% I think that would indicate a
collapse of the company if you could
knock it down to like 55% there needs to
be another sales drop off before uh May
yeah it have to impact people that
already didn't it didn't impact already
it have to have new people that are
saying okay now I'm politically aware
and I'm willing to stop drinking Bud
Light alt together or the narrative can
be Shan Strickland said a bunch of
transphobic things and their sales
recovered yeah pick your narrative it's
up to you if you haven't already my
friends would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends become a
member at
timcast.net and jokes and comedy and
offense culture on the members only show
coming up in about a minute you can
follow the show at timcast IRL you can
follow me personally at timcast Anna do
you want to shout anything out uh yeah
you can uh follow me on Twitter at Anna
Perez DC sorry I'm not in the microphone
uh Anna Perez DC and then also you can
follow me on Instagram at wrongthink
anore so yeah Anna that was great thank
you so much for coming on I am now
officially partnered with Rumble and
that's why I launched the best political
show.com we we actually will be having
Dave Smith on tomorrow 600 p.m. Eastern
and then the day after that James
Lindsay so uh definitely go check it out
members of lukan filter.com gets to call
in and it is thepolitical show.com and
I'm Ian crosson follow me on the
internet everywhere at Ian crosson
subscribe on YouTube I just did an
interview with Dave landow it was
spectacular over the weekend great guy
go check it out talk to me about Serge
uh yeah uh thanks for coming appreciate
it thanks for having me of course um
yeah I don't know find me on the
internet se.com we'll see you all over
at timcast.net